Nice!
Ja Patrick, ich hätte das gemacht, ich hätte jetzt live im Stream, hätte ich Streamprofile signiert, hättest du nicht den Channel gelöscht.
Was macht ihr eigentlich alle schon hier? Habt ihr alle nichts zu tun?
Jetzt sind die Leute am Start, ja schneller als gestern Abend.
Vorgestern Abend.
Oder wann auch immer ich zuletzt on war.
Gestern Morgen, 0W.
Pausechamp.
Homeoffice, beste, ja.
Muss ich morgen auch wieder.
Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht genau wie lange ich...
Der 8.00 Uhr der Wettmanns ist auch am Start.
Oder was von Logitech gehört.
Bin ja gespannt was da rauskommt.
Wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau.
Ich weiß nicht wie lange ich genau on bin.
Ich will ein bisschen rum basteln.
Also die Sache ist, ich hab gerade übelst Pepo Happy Fett gemacht.
Ich hab wieder...
Ich hab euch doch letztens gezeigt, ich hab mir doch so Nudeln und Soßen probierpaket bestellt aus Italien.
Ich hab heute Rigatoni...
Oder wie spricht man das überhaupt richtig aus?
Rigatoni...
Rigatoni, keine Ahnung.
Und mit...
Riga...
Und mit Tomatensauce aus dem Glas, was ich da bestellt hab.
Ist zwar nicht billig, aber schmeckt echt...
Eis.
Und ich bin jetzt so voll gefressen, dass ich jetzt die Auswahl hab.
Entweder ich setz mich jetzt vor den Rechner.
Und penn wahrscheinlich einen dabei, weil ich so voll gefressen bin.
Oder...
Ich mach einfach Stream an.
Exzellent.
Ich mach jetzt einfach Stream an, dann muss ich ein bisschen schwätzen und kann nicht einpennen.
Das heißt...
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, wie lang ich es durchhalte.
Ja.
Und...
Ich hab gedacht, wir können eine Sache machen, die ich mir schon eine Weile angucken wollte.
Nämlich Tailwind CSS.
Ihr wisst ja, ich bin kein...
Krasser Design, so was Frontend angeht.
Muss ich erstmal die VM anmachen.
Oder ich hab irgendwas im Auge.
Genau, und zwar...
Alter, was hab ich denn im Auge hängen?
Das sackt ja mal richtig, Alter.
So.
Und zwar, ich bin ja nicht der tolle...
Design-Mensch, was Frontend angeht.
Ich hab das bisher zum größten Teil eigentlich immer hiermit gemacht.
Hoch.
So.
Und dann immer...
Hoch.
Also bisher verwende ich fürs Frontend...
Ja, Nudeln, genau.
Was ist das für ein Kokona-Hintergrund, Alter?
Massive Kokona-Style.
Was ist das für ein Bing?
Das ist Bing-Image of the day.
Hell yeah.
Wo ist die M16?
By the way, der einzige Service, wofür ich Bing verwende, Image of the day.
So.
Bisher mach ich mein Frontend-Kram ja hauptsächlich damit, weil ich ein Kacknoob bin.
Und von Design keine Ahnung habe.
Deswegen mach ich das immer damit.
Weil das ist easy as fuck, ja.
Da ist das mehr oder weniger alles schon fertig.
Wenn ich so eine Karte machen will, dann mach ich hier Karten, mach drei Buttons rein und dann sieht das so aus.
So.
Das mach ich bisher damit.
Aber der neueste Shit ist jetzt...
Was heißt der neueste? So neu ist das gar nicht.
Aber voll angesagt ist jetzt das hier aktuell.
Tailwind-CSS.
Und im Prinzip muss man da die Sachen...
Also wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab.
Dann macht man damit das Design nach wie vor komplett selbst.
Aber es ist wohl einfacher und schneller zu...
Zu...
Sagt man so schön Prototypen.
Als direkt CSS zu programmieren.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Ich bin schlechter Frontend-Designer, was das angeht.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich probier das mal aus.
Ich wollte es schon eine ganze Weile ausprobieren.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, komm, machen wir das nicht jetzt einfach mal im Stream.
Aber wenn man sich die Tailwind-Homepage anguckt...
Dann sind nur Mädels am Tailwind programmieren.
Guck hier, hier oben.
Da.
Da fühl ich mich ja nicht included, äh.
Gleich...
Deinstallieren.
Genau.
Frontendgrills, genau.
Das stimmt aber tatsächlich.
Ist aber echt so.
Also, wenn ich mal bei uns auf der Arbeit gucke, wie sich das verteilt.
Also.
Also, ich nehm jetzt mal nur IT-Sachen, ja.
In der Personalabteilung sind zu 90% Mädels.
Das lass ich jetzt mal außen vor.
Wenn ich mal bei uns auf der Arbeit gucke.
Also, im Admin-Bereich haben wir genau eine.
Und die macht Datenbankzeug.
So.
Das sind quasi 99% Männer.
Ähm.
Dann.
Im Software-Entwicklungsbereich.
Da weiß ich, dass wir.
Also, ist ja viel Java.
Java-Backend-Gedöns und sowas.
Da weiß ich zumindest, dass wir noch zwei Stück haben.
Aber von insgesamt fragt mich nicht.
Massig, massig Kerlen.
Das sind auch keine 95% Männer.
Aber es gibt zwei Bereiche.
Da muss man sagen, da haben wir auch tatsächlich relativ viele.
Wo ist sie leiser?
Relativ viele Mädels.
Und.
Alter, der Chat, der will wieder alles falsch verstehen.
Und zwar, wir haben im Frontend-Bereich.
Und in IOS-Apps.
Haben wir relativ viele.
Also, IOS besteht bei uns gefühlt zu viel.
Aber es gibt zwei Bereiche.
Da muss man sagen, da haben wir auch tatsächlich relativ viele.
Also, IOS besteht bei uns gefühlt zu 50-50.
Aus Mädels und Kerlen.
Und.
So Frontend-Design.
Gedöns würde ich auch mal sagen.
50-50.
Also, es ist tatsächlich gar nicht so weit hergeholt.
Im Frontend-Bereich gibt es tatsächlich ganz viele Mädels.
Wobei, bei uns Frontend.
Wisst ihr, was bei uns Frontend bedeutet?
Zum größten Teil.
Ratet mal.
Was heißt bei uns Frontend?
Okay, der Chat hat keine Ahnung.
Nee, ich würde mal sagen, ganz großer Teil ist
WordPress immer noch.
Das war klar.
WordPress.
Nein, aber nicht nur.
Aber es ist viel WordPress.
Und.
Ja, was wir da so alles haben.
Ist zum größten Teil WordPress.
Und die Sache ist halt die.
Diese WordPress-Dinger.
Die sind ja irgendwie auch.
Nein, nicht unkaputtbar ist das falsche Wort.
Die sind hartnäckig.
Die Website ist.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube, das ist kein WordPress.
Die Homepage.
Ach so.
Nee, das ist kein WordPress.
Das ist irgendwas, was irgendein polnischer Anbieter
programmiert hat für uns.
Und das geile ist.
Die haben mittlerweile.
Total viel Zeug so outsourced.
Ich mache mal übrigens gerade nebenbei Betriebssystem-Updater.
Die haben total viel Zeug so outsourced, dass das jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr.
Was ist denn mit der Musik los?
Die kann immer einheitlich laut sein.
Dass das überhaupt nicht mehr richtig zusammenpasst.
Du hast dann.
Du hast irgendwelche WordPress-Geschichten da.
Dann hast du irgendwelche Custom-CMS-Sachen da.
Dann hast du irgendwie Java.
Und.
Bei dem anderen ist sogar noch ein.
Angular-Frontend.
Also das ist total wirr.
Es passt überhaupt nichts zusammen.
Und dementsprechend.
Freuen sich glaube ich nur die Stonks-Männer.
Aktuell.
Dass das.
So geil cloud ist alles.
Too much information.
Ihr habt eh nichts davon wenn ihr es wisst.
Nee, aber das ist witzig.
Das ganze Outgesource.
Das geht immer nur vordergründig gut.
Patrick, ich habe das ernsthaft mal in einem Stream geleakt.
Wirklich?
Was ist das?
Ich habe das ernsthaft mal in einem Stream geleakt.
Wirklich?
Schreibt mir mal please im Discord.
Was ich da geleakt habe im Stream.
Kann ich mich gar nicht dran erinnern.
Hab ich versprochen oder so?
Naja egal.
Okay habe ich Updates durch hier.
Excellent, excellent alles klar.
Ich habe noch ein Update gemacht.
Ich reboote nochmal.
Ich weiß nicht ob es neue Kernel gibt.
Trunk Stream.
So ultra Trunk Stream habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich war am Silvester mal ein bisschen bestoffen.
Aber das war es eigentlich.
Gibt es hier einen neuen Kernel?
Zeige ich mal da.
Nope wir haben das Alleraktuellste.
Poggers.
Massive Poggers.
Oh nee Leute.
Ich muss Javascript Zeug aktualisieren.
Wie macht man das überhaupt?
Update so?
Jetzt müssen wir das halbe Internet
downloaden.
Das ist mal ein Jaro.
Kann ich sowas hier machen?
Global Update?
Nee.
Upgrade.
Das ist alles klar.
So.
Internet Download läuft.
Das ist ein LTS Kernel.
Ja aber das ist doch trotzdem der aktuellste.
Gerade oder?
War das nicht gerade erst rausgekommen?
Das ist doch der letzte.
Das ist auch ein LTS.
Ist das ein LTS?
Stimmt doch.
Das müsste eigentlich ein LTS sein.
Das ist ein LTS.
Ja das ist ein LTS.
Nice.
Da kann ich ihn auch eine Weile behalten.
So.
Hat er jetzt geupdatet?
Ok. Internet Zeug ist aktualisiert.
Javascript Zeug ist aktualisiert.
Sehr gut.
Ist das so?
Ich verfolge das überhaupt nicht.
Ich benutze den Kram nur und
wenn die sich da irgendwo anders auskotzen wollen
kein Schimmer.
Das ist auch geil.
Das ist bei diesem Javascript
Zeug übrigens normal.
Wenn du irgendwas installierst und irgendwas machst
du kriegst erst mal 20 Millionen Warnings
und kannst im Endeffekt nichts dagegen machen.
Ok.
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung davon.
Vielleicht sollten wir erst mal gucken
ob es irgendwelche Visual Studio Addons gibt.
Für diesen Kram.
Was haben wir hier eigentlich alles rumliegen?
Wie viele Temp-Orgner habe ich jetzt schon?
Temp, Temp 2, Temp 0.
Ok.
Dann fehlt jetzt eindeutig noch
Temp, Keg, W.
Temp, Keg, W fehlt noch.
So ist das gut. Da machen wir das jetzt drin.
Temp, Temp.
Auf der Arbeit ist ganz schrecklich.
Ich hatte ja da schon
einige VMs, Notebooks und sonst was
und ich hab halt immer meinen Home-Folder kopiert.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit sieht es wirklich so aus.
Hier in Home.
Home, Max.
Home, Max, Old.
Home, Max, Old, Old.
Home, Max, Old, Old, Old.
Home, Max, Old, Old, Old, Old, Old.
Meine Festplatte ist gefühlt
zur Hälfte nur mit alten Home-Foldern voll.
Aber zum Glück
zum Glück ist jedes Mal die
SSD oder die Festplatte in Notebooks
größer. Das ist nicht auf.
Das macht nichts.
Hab ich euch mal erzählt, dass ich
auf der Arbeit einmal beschwert habe
dass ich indirekt zu
Hacker-Man bin und zwar ich hab
auf einem
internen Fileserver
den's gibt
für PowerPoint-Vorlagen
und solche Dinger
hab ich
mein Linux-Backup drauf gemacht.
Und das war dann halt irgendwie frag mich nicht 200G
oder so. Ich hab einfach die ganze Festplatte
die ganze SSD inklusive VM-Images
und alles drauf, drauf Backup
mit Borg-Backup
und irgendwann war ich dann auf diesem
Fileserver derjenige dann irgendwie
die Hälfte an Speicherplatz verwendet hat.
Ich mein irgendwo hin muss ich
Backups machen, ja.
Und es ist dann irgendwann aufgefallen, dass
das irgendwie keine
PowerPoint-Folien sind und sonstige Dinger.
Äh, nutzt du
bei der Arbeit nur Linux oder wirst du gezwungen
auch Windows laufen zu haben? Oh, das ist ein schönes
Thema.
Also
aktuell hab ich's auf der Arbeit so
ich hab ein Linux-Notebook
und, ähm
zwei Windows-VMs.
Das ist das Wollen, das ist
irgendwie neue Policy. Es gibt eine VM
mit vielen Freischaltungen für Admins
und eine normale Arbeits-Windows-VM.
So, und dann hab ich halt mein Notebook noch am Start.
So, wunderbar. Ist eigentlich auch
ganz cool. Mit, auch mit
Manjaro, mit der gleichen Config.
Hier.
Mit, hier, mit der gleichen Config drauf.
So, und
Und jetzt
ist es so
Irgendjemand
ist auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen
dass, ich hab euch ja erzählt wir hatten
letztes Mal Probleme mit so einem Verschlüsselungs-
Trojaner. Oder was Trojaner?
So ein Verschlüsselungs-Ding, was dann angefangen hat
Windows-Filesäuber zu verschlüsseln und so was.
Was witzig ist, dass keines der
Linux-Systeme betroffen war. Aber gut, aber gut.
Deswegen haben wir jetzt überall
Windows-Defender. Ergibt auch
Habt ihr schonmal Windows-Defender unter
Linux betrieben? Ich weiß jetzt
wie geil das ist.
Wir haben jetzt auf der Arbeit nämlich per Policy
auf fast allen Linux-Kisten
haben wir Windows-Defender drauf. Ist jetzt kein Witz.
Ist jetzt kein Witz.
Das gibt's, jaja. Das heißt
Microsoft
Advanced
Threat Protection oder so.
ATP
Microsoft
Advanced Threat Protection
Das gibt's auch
für Linux. Das ist Advanced, ja.
Microsoft-Defender
ADP. Ja, Ding Crap.
Haben wir da jetzt
drauf. Und das Ding macht nur
Probleme, ne?
Wir haben Mail-Server und sonstige
Dinge. Die haben jetzt 50% CPU-Auslastung
nur
nur wegen dem
Microsoft-Antivirus.
Und das Geile ist, es ist dann letztens
rausgekommen, der Microsoft-Antivirus
ist sogar nur im
Log-Only-Modus, nicht im Scan-
und Mach-Modus. Was im Prinzip
bedeutet, wenn man das Ding richtig
schalten würde,
macht es dann
80% CPU-Last?
Oder was?
Das ist
wirklich Ultra-Crap-Advanced-CPU-
Usage.
ACU ist das dann.
So, genau, und
wieder auf diese
Frage zurückzukommen. Und dann
haben sie sich jetzt überlegt, es ist jetzt
Pflicht für alle bei uns auf der Arbeit,
kommt jetzt demnächst, dass man
Windows verwendet, also sprich auf
die Notebooks. Also im Prinzip,
ich mach dann mein Linux halt auf
eine VM drauf, ist eigentlich im Prinzip auch
kein Problem. Aktuell arbeite ich inno-
Remote PSSH, das juckt mich jetzt nicht
großartig. Aber ich bin
dann schon mal gespannt,
wie viel länger manche Sachen dauern, weil
Copy und Paste nicht richtig funktioniert
zwischen Windows und Linux.
Wenn ich manche Sachen nicht
mal nachinstallieren kann,
wenn ich nicht einfach mal einen TCP-Dump
kann oder irgendwas, da bin ich schon mal
gespannt drauf, wie viel,
wie oft dann Leute cackwaiten,
weil ich ihnen sagen muss, funktioniert
halt nicht richtig. Ja, also, ja
WSL, nee, WSL2
ist nicht möglich, WSL1.
Für WSL2 ist
unser Windows zu alt.
Aber es ist letztendlich wurscht,
WSL geht,
WSL ist halbwegs
wirklich, ja. Also,
WSL ist okay, was mir halt ein bisschen
fehlt, ist, dass man
grafische Programme gescheit
verwenden kann, aber da gibt es ja mittlerweile
Möglichkeiten, die allerdings tatsächlich nicht so gut
funktionieren, wirklich, wie mit einem richtigen, echten
Xover unter Linux.
Mal gucken,
es wird bestimmt, es wird bestimmt witzig.
Aber mittlerweile mache ich mir da gar keine Gedanken
mehr drüber, weil
letztendlich bezahlen die mich
dann fürs nichts machen.
Also, wenn es halt nicht geht,
dann kann ich auch nichts für.
Dankeschön, Sarix, für den
zwei Monate Sub.
Sorry, falls ich irgendwelche Subs
vergessen habe, ich scroll mal kurz ganz schnell
drüber, ich glaube nicht, nee, nicht.
Passive Subscriptions hier.
Was die wollen bei uns
danach,
was die wollen bei uns,
ein Panda-Antivirus,
was zum...
Soviel Crap, ich weiß gar nicht,
was mit den Leuten los ist, warum die so scharf
draußen sind, sich Müll zu installieren.
Hey Max, bin gestern über
ein China-Kram, kommt da eigentlich nochmal
ähm,
ich hab in letzter Zeit nicht so viel
Interessantes da, was ich zeigen könnte,
gekauft.
Und das Video hat jetzt auch nicht so viele Leute
interessiert, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da nochmal eins
mache.
Advanced Agile
Antivirus, ja.
Oh, das ist eklig.
Also, muss sagen, wirklich gute
Open Source-Antivirus gibt's nicht, aber
man kann sich generell darüber streiten, ob es überhaupt
guten Antivirus gibt.
Aber wie gesagt, es gibt
Microsoft Windows Defender
oder Microsoft Defender
auch für Linux, ja.
Wahrscheinlich auch für Mac.
Wann kommt Schneestells?
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht lad ich den Schneestells sogar als nächstes
hoch, weil ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, was ich als richtig echtes Video
aufnehmen sollte. Kann ich einfach
am Mittwoch oder so den Schneestells
hochladen und hab dann wieder vier Tage Luft, wo ich mir
was überlegen kann. Ich hab mir so überlegt,
dass ich alle vier bis fünf Tage
was hochlade.
Kommt ja eigentlich auch ganz gut
hin. Und Schneestells,
wenn jetzt der Schnee überall wieder weg ist,
ist eigentlich besonders gut.
Okay, also, wie benutzt
man den Kram jetzt? Wir haben einen neuen Ordner.
Exzellent.
Wir haben
bei uns auf der Arbeit
unter Windows Kaspersky
am Start, glaube.
Und das ist auch geil.
Da sind die Commodits immer direkt
am Start.
Das hat
dieses Verschlüsselungsding nicht erkannt.
Und jetzt haben sie Kaspersky
und Windows Defender zusammen
am Start, glaube, auf dem
Windows Sachen.
Das kommt sich wahrscheinlich dann auch noch in die Quere.
Die Quere.
Okay, also
fangen wir mal an. Ich wollte mir
Vue.js angucken. Als erstes, also Betriebssystem
geupdatet. Hab ich schon wunderbar.
Ich wollte mal schnell gucken,
ob es Visual Studio Code Extensions für gibt.
Aber vorher müssen wir ein Projekt anlegen. Also,
Integration Guides.
Ich würde ja gerne
ein Vue.js Projekt nehmen.
Aber anscheinend geht das nicht.
Doch, Vue 3 kann man nehmen. Alles klar.
Okay, wie findest du das? Zeig mal her.
Aha, NPM. Jan ist
out, ne? Leute, JavaScript
entwickelt sich so schnell,
da blickst du nicht mal durch.
Also, es gibt ja als Paketmanager
so Jan und NPM.
NPM für Node.
Und vor
zwei Jahren war NPM
übelst
verpönt bei manchen.
Und da war Jan voll angesagt.
Und jetzt
ist Jan nicht mehr angesagt
und NPM wieder voll innen.
Ist Deno eigentlich schon wieder tot? Ne, oder?
Deno ist voll, voll,
geht immer noch gut ab.
Ja. Ist nicht
tot.
Jan hat's verkackt
mit Jan 2. Weil Jan
2 nicht mehr, nicht mehr kompatibel
zu Jan 1 ist.
Total, total verschissen, ja.
Und bei Deno
bin ich ja mal gespannt,
ob das
weite Verbreitung finden wird.
Weil, also im Prinzip ist Deno
quasi ein Node mit eingebautem
TypeScript Support und noch ein bisschen mehr.
Nur, dass es kein Node ist.
Sondern Rust
und V8 Bindings und frag mir nicht.
Ist Jay
nicht auch inzwischen unmaintained?
Ernsthaft? Wollen die mich veräppeln?
Ich hab erst
den Joghurt verwendet, der war unmaintained.
Dann hab ich Tritzen verwendet, das war
Perl und hat gesackt, dann hab ich Jay verwendet
und jetzt ist das auch unmaintained?
Wirklich?
Ne.
Vor 16, vor 16
meint mich nicht.
Vor 16 Stunden wurde da zuletzt
was, was, Dings.
Das ist nicht unmaintained. Passt.
Alles gut.
Ist das so?
Eben haben meine
JIT Packages Updates bekommen.
JIT.
Meine JIT Packages.
Ja, und
obwohl ich mich frage bei Deno, ob das
nennenswerte Verbreitung
findet, ist
eines der größten Vorteile
von Node ist ja gerade,
dass es so viele
Packages gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ob die
irgendwelche Statistiken haben, wieviel Packages
das da insgesamt am Start sind.
Weiß nicht, haben die Stats
oder so?
Keine Ahnung, ob man sieht, wieviel Packages da
insgesamt
oder eh nicht.
Es gibt Milliarden
NPN Packages gefühlt
und Deno kann die halt nicht verwenden.
Deswegen frage ich mich halt,
wie gut das
sich verbreitet.
Also,
das ist ja
sich verbreitet.
Man kann jetzt von
Node halten, was man will, aber
das NPM Ökosystem ist schon ganz
nice. Auch wenn ich mich immer gerne
drüber lustig mache, dass wenn du ein Update machst, der alles
nachinstalliert, das halbe Internet, aber
Max, erzähl mal bitte
Geschichte zum Shit Repo. Hab ich doch schon
total oft? Soll ich? Ich
wollte jetzt eigentlich was machen.
Okay, ich erzähl euch ganz
kurz die Geschichte zum Shit Repo.
Aber nur in zwei Minuten.
Und zwar, wir hatten
mal einen Azubi bei uns.
Und
der hatte nicht so den
allergrößten Durchblick. Ich glaube,
der war
in dem Beruf nicht richtig.
Und
der ist jetzt auch Junior Consultant
irgendwo.
Also, Junior Consultant ist so das
Aufhangbecken für alle, die nichts können.
Naja,
zumindest, der konnte
durchaus was, aber halt
nichts Technisches.
Ich glaube, verkaufen kann der Typ echt nicht schlecht.
So, und
der war
bei uns mal zwei, drei Monate
am Start. Und wir hatten damals jemand
bei uns im Team, der hat die Sachen alle so
super geil ausgesprochen. Der hat
dann gesagt, Jyra, wobei
Jyra ja so halbwegs noch stimmt,
Jit und
und
Jubantu und was auch immer.
Der hat alles super geil ausgesprochen.
Und der Azubi hat das halt
sich angehört und gedacht, so
spricht man die Sachen aus.
Das Problem ist nur, dass man halt Jit
nicht Jit ausspricht.
Und der Azubi hat es halt dann auch noch ein bisschen
falsch ausgesprochen. Und bei uns ist das so, dass die
Azubis nach irgendwie, fragt mich nicht einmal
im halben Jahr oder so, müssen immer eine
Präsentation halten über das, was sie in dem
letzten halben Jahr gemacht haben. Und dann stand
der halt oben, wo Leute auch vom
Vorstand dabei waren, das ist bei uns
übelste Anzugträgerveranstaltung.
Das ist so Prestigeting immer.
Und da sind immer die ganzen
Oberstonksleute dabei und
die Azubis scheißen sich immer halb in die Hose.
Wenn sie da hin mussten.
Naja, zumindest
doch, da spricht man so aus.
Zumindest
so war der dann halt dort am Start.
Und hat dann seine Vorstellungen gemacht.
Und hat dann halt vor diesen Leuten
gestanden, die halt, muss man halt dazu sagen,
die haben technisch absolut gar keinen Plan.
Die Leute, die da sitzen, ja null.
Bis auf zwei, drei Leute, die halt dabei
eingeladen wurden und halt zufällig mal dabei sind.
Und er hat dann halt oben vor diesen ganzen
Anzugleuten gestanden und hat gesagt,
er hat Sachen eingecheckt in das
Shitrepo.
Und die haben sich halt total entgeistert
und empört schon angeguckt.
Was ist mit dem los?
Will der jetzt besonders cool klingen oder was?
Was ist hier los? Was soll das hier bedeuten?
Shit, so was geht hier.
Die waren schon quasi kurz vor der Abmahnung im Endeffekt.
Und bis ihn dann einer gerettet hat,
eine, eine,
bis ihn dann eine gerettet hat und meinte halt
ach hier,
du meinst unser Gitrepo.
Und dann meinte er so, ja ja, hab ich doch gesagt.
Er meinte, er hat eigentlich, wisst ihr,
die haben gedacht, er macht jetzt so den
freestylen Rap. Ich hab's eingecheckt
in das Shitrepo.
Und das meinte er halt nicht.
Und das ist bei uns
mittlerweile so der Running Gag.
Wir sagen ja mittlerweile auch
nicht mehr, keiner, keiner bei uns
auf der Arbeit, mit dem ich öfters
was, was da zu tun hab,
auch Git-mäßig sagt noch Git.
Wir sagen alle Shit.
Wir sagen alle was. So eine
Anlehnung an diese Geschichte ist Shit.
Auch wenn wir jeder wissen, das
spricht man nicht so aus, ja.
Shit.
So.
Okay, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich sollte irgendwas installieren,
steht da. Also, View 3.
Dann machen wir das mit View 3.
Da war das der C-Lattenzaun-Typ.
Korrekt.
Ja.
Laut dem gleichen Azubi heißt sie
hat auch C-Lattenzaun.
GIF weiß ich nicht. GIF.
Wobei GIF ist bestimmt
ein GIF bei dem. Auch GIF, Alter.
Genau, bei dem hat es auch C-Lattenzaun.
Ja, nein, der hat nicht getrollt.
Der wusste das einfach nicht.
Na komm.
C-Router hat doch jeder auch schon mal
irgendwo gehört.
Der hat nicht getrollt. Der wusste es
einfach nicht.
Ob das das... Nein, mittlerweile war das was.
Und das witzige war,
ich hab
ich hab den ja sogar mal was in C-Lattenzaun
programmieren lassen und zwar
so einen BMI-Rechner. Also BMI-Rechner,
dass man, dass man erkennt, ob man
richtig schön pepo fett ist.
Nee, einfach nur weil es eine easy
Übung ist, ja.
Und BMI-Rechner, also nach dem Motto
geben sie, geben sie ihre Größe ein, geben
sie ihr Gewicht ein und sowas, dann rechnet er
das aus.
Und
das war halt auch der gleiche
Azubi, der dann irgendwann
nach frag mich nicht, der hat zwei Tagen oder so
rumgemacht an so einem BMI-Rechner. Das sind
fünf Zeilen Code oder so. Da kann
nicht allzu viel passieren. Normalerweise
allzu viel schiefgehen. Zwei Tage hat er
da rumgewusst und hat es nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Irgendwann kommt er dann zu mir
und meint so, Max, es funktioniert,
es funktioniert.
Da hab ich gesagt, ja, zeig mal her. Und im Endeffekt,
was er gemeint hat, hat halt, ja, okay,
es hat zum ersten Mal richtig kompiliert.
Er hat keinen
Fehler gekriegt, bei mir fünf drücken.
So. Und
dann hat er so ein Programm
gehabt, da stand dann so was da wie
geben sie
ihr
Gewicht in Kilogramm ein.
So was hatte der dann. Und dann hab ich
dann einfach mal eingegeben
Hallo. Und dann ist das Programm gecrashed.
Und dann hat er gemeint, nein, das darfst du
noch nicht eingeben. Du musst da Zahlen
eingeben. Und ich sag, ja, wo
soll ich jetzt
wissen?
Und dann war er wieder
ganz aufgelöst.
Oh Mann.
Ja, das war schon witzig.
Der war nicht blöd.
Der war, der war
auf seine Art sogar relativ
Fivehead.
Also der hatte echt Talent dafür.
Das hab ich so auch
selten erlebt. Und zwar.
Der konnte
on the fly
wechseln von
Er hat Ahnung zu, er hat keine Ahnung.
Prizerief
Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub.
Also sprich
normalerweise merkst du das. Wenn
wahrgenommen, ihr habt irgendwelche
Verkaufsleute
da, die euch jetzt irgendwie neues Ticketsystem
anpreisen wollen. Und die erzählen
dann und du fragst sie was, die erzählen
und meistens merkst du relativ
relativ genau
wenn die Leute anfangen
keine Ahnung mehr zu haben.
Das hört man eigentlich ganz gut raus.
Von
sie wissen wovon sie reden zu.
Sie sagen einfach nur irgendwas, dass es einem gefällt.
Das merkt, das hörst du eigentlich relativ schnell raus.
Und der hatte echt ein Talent dafür
diesen Übergang möglichst
fließend zu gestalten. Also sprich, der
konnte ja was erzählen. Und
dann konnte der genau so
gleiche Tonlage, gleiche Aussagekraft
so, gleiche
Aussprache hat, konnte der weiterreden
und er wusste nicht mehr wovon
er redet. Also eigentlich, das wird
das ist bestimmt der Super Junior
Consultant Verkäufer, der Typ mittlerweile.
Problem ist
nur, wenn auf der anderen
Seite jemand sitzt, der halt weiß
was er erzählt.
Und Fips
ja genau, das ist der, der halben Nervenzusammenbruch
wegen
Netzwerkfragen von mir hatte.
Der arme Kerl, da habe ich
heute echt immer noch ein bisschen schlechtes Gewissen.
Da hätte ich ehrlich gesagt
eigentlich hätte ich da nicht mit rechnen können.
Aber
da hat er mir echt leid getan.
Ja
Oh man, das war schon was.
Der Herr N-Punkt
Der Herr N-Punkt B-Punkt
Ich hoffe aber dem gehts gut
und ich hoffe auch, der hat jetzt was ordentliches gefunden, was zu ihm passt.
Naja, wie dem auch sei.
Also was soll ich denn machen, um Tailwind ausprobieren zu können?
Mit View 3 und White.
Was war denn nochmal White?
Ich kenne View-CLA
und ich kenne auch
ich kenne View-CLA
was zum Geier ist White?
Warum
heißt es White und nicht
Black oder so?
Warum White?
Das ist doch ganz verpönt heutzutage.
Oder wenigstens
Pride
Es sollte Pride heißen, nicht
White
Egal
Ich habe dir noch dummes Teufel erzählt, was ist denn das?
White.js
Schau wieder was neues, please!
Gibt es irgendwann mal eine Woche, wo keine neuen JavaScript-Frameworks entstehen?
Moment, das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Da war das nicht dieser Bundler
von den View.js Leuten?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Ich mache einfach, was da in dem Getting Started steht.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, ich wollte
eigentlich, eigentlich wollte ich ein View-CLA-Projekt machen.
Egal, egal.
Das hast du letztens erst angeschaut.
Ja, genau, deswegen kam mir das auch bekannt vor.
Das ist dieser Bundler von den View.js Leuten.
Okay.
Das ist der Bundler von den View.js Leuten.
Okay, wir machen jetzt einfach mal
so, wie man das immer machen muss
bei JavaScript, einfach
random irgendwelche Befehle aus dem Internet ausführen.
Also
My Project.
Nein, das heißt, doch, doch.
Wir bleiben jetzt einfach mal bei dem Beispiel.
View?
Lit.
Lit-Element.
Also
Vanilla kann ich mir vorstellen.
Vanilla ist JavaScript.
View, View TypeScript.
React, React TypeScript.
Was zum Geier ist Preact?
Ach so.
JavaScript, Alter.
JavaScript.
Und was ist Lit-Element?
Doch, Lit-Element
kenne ich. Lit-Element, das
kenne ich, das ist
Web-Components.
Irgendein Web-Components
Helper-Framework oder so.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Okay, wir machen, stinkt nochmal. Kein TypeScript,
einfach stinkt nochmal das View3-Projekt.
Excellent, okay. CD.
Wir brauchen Peter Agile.
Genau, das ist
Preact rendert schon bevor
der User überhaupt auf die Webseite geht.
Ja, proaktiv hat man da zu
früher gesagt. Quasi
predicted rendering
oder so.
Das rendert einfach schon mal in der Hoffnung,
der User geht in nächster Zeit
drauf.
Eigentlich Big, sowas sollten,
eigentlich ein übelst geiler Idee, sowas müssen wir erfinden,
Leute.
AI-based rendering.
Wir predikten
einfach, wann der User die Webseite
besucht und dann rendern
wir schon mal. Und
wir wissen das irgendwann besser als der User
selbst, wann er auf die Webseite geht.
Okay, also CD.
Nee, haben wir schon. Also NPM install.
Excellent, excellent, alles klar.
Okay, halbes Internet.
Halbes Internet wird installiert.
Übrigens, das Geile ist wirklich,
jedes Mal, wenn du NPM
ausführst, bestehen erstmal
12.000 warnings.
Ja, und
wenn man das Ganze noch renden lässt in Stadia,
hat man auch negative Latenz, genau.
Okay, was haben wir jetzt hier? Tailwind AI,
ich hab aktuell das Note. Install
Tailwind mit NPM.
Das installiert aber nicht nur
Tailwind, das installiert Tailwind,
PostCSS und den Autoprefixer.
Der Autoprefixer.
Der macht wahrscheinlich
automatisch Präfixes.
Sowas wie minusminuswebkit
oder
sowas.
Vermute ich einfach mal.
Der Autoprefixed.
Leute, danach machen wir
mal einen
DU und gucken, wie groß das Projekt ist.
Wartet mal.
Das ist aber nicht viel.
Nur 84 MB.
Das ist ja nichts.
Also für JavaScript ist das ja
das ist ja quasi
Hello World.
84 MB.
Hör mal auf.
Da geht so ein ordentliches JavaScript-Projekt
gar nicht mal los.
Das ist ja
ganz einfach.
Das JavaScript-Projekt gar nicht mal los.
Mit 84 MB.
Lightweight JS.
Ja.
84 MB.
Normales Projekt hat nach einem NPM-Install
das muss mindestens
2,5G haben, dass das überhaupt
alles wichtige dabei hat.
Okay, also.
Kennst du das Framework
JS? Wie gibt es das ernsthaft?
Ich dachte immer mit Vanilla ist
einfach schlicht und ergreifend gemeint
JavaScript ohne irgendwelche
Zusatzsachen.
Ach, das ist ein Witz. Okay, verstehe.
Ja, gut.
Wenigstens verappeln sich die JavaScript-Leute
mittlerweile selbst.
Okay, und jetzt machen wir NPX.
Den Unterschied zwischen NPM
und NPX habe ich noch nicht kapiert.
Was?
NPM versus NPX.
What's the difference?
Genau, erzähl mal.
NPM ist der Package
Manager und NPX.
Warte.
Auch nicht,
schon wieder dieser nervige Spam,
Alter.
So.
Klickt die Kacke links nicht an,
Instantsperren.
NPM Execute.
Ja, warum kann man nicht einfach NPM Run
verwenden? NPM Run mit irgendeinem
Script, warum braucht man dann extra
dafür?
Okay.
Wir hinterfragen das einfach nicht, so ist es
halt im JavaScript-Land.
Exzellent. Jetzt haben wir eine
Tailwind-Config-CS und eine
Post-CSS-Config-GS.
Alles klar.
This will create minimal
Tailwind-Config.
Keine Sorge, wir machen das nicht
mit Vim, wir machen das gleich mit VS Code,
aber ich will mal gucken, ob das stimmt, was die da erzählen.
Genau, passt.
Alles klar, hat er erstellt.
Post-CSS-Config.
Hat er auch erstellt,
nix drin.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
ob ich Post-CSS-Plugins brauche.
Ich wusste bis eben noch nicht mal, dass Post-CSS
überhaupt existiert.
Configure Tailwind to remove
unused styles input.
Ach, was?
Ich habe gern
15 MB Webseiten.
Das bleibt so.
Include Tailwind in your
CSS.
Wait, was?
Create source index
CSS.
Okay. Source?
Was? Index CSS?
Und da soll ich
den Kram jetzt reinpasten.
Okay.
Warum genau hat es dieser NPM
Generator nicht gemacht für mich?
Aha.
Finally in your
Main?
Ach hier, da soll ich das importieren.
Okay.
Ich mache
einfach nur Tutorial
Held.
Also.
You're finished.
Echt.
Das war's
schon.
Nur 5
kryptische Sachen machen müssen.
Okay. NPM run dev.
Alles klar. Excellent.
Und jetzt?
Aha.
Und das ist jetzt?
Oh.
Poggers.
Test App.
So.
Excellent.
Okay.
Nice. Und das war's jetzt?
Oder wie?
Alles klar.
Gut. Dann machen wir das Ganze
mal auf.
Beste Webseite, ja.
So. Dann machen wir den ganzen Krempel hier mal auf.
Machen wir Visual Studio Code auf. Und
schieben das mal auf den
Desktop. Hier machen wir run.
NPM dev.
Machen wir das Ding in Chromo. Schieben es auf
auf den dritten Desktop. Und jetzt gucken wir mal.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wenigstens so live reload
und solche Sachen funktionieren.
Was will der hier eigentlich von mir?
Okay. Source.
Please edit components.
Reload.
Excellent.
Ja.
Darf ich jetzt anfangen? Hello World.
Okay. Also wenn ich jetzt hier drin...
Ja, ist ja gut.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier drin irgendwas editier,
dann...
Oh. Funktioniert sogar. Guckt euch das mal an.
Der reloaded automatisch.
So. Und wenn ich jetzt hier oben reinschreibe
CACW, dann steht dann da
nicht CACW. Doch da!
Da steht CACW. Tatsächlich. Okay.
Also live reload funktioniert. Gut.
Wie funktioniert das jetzt
mit...
mit Tailwind? Ich hab legit
keinen Plan. Ich hab nur mal
gesehen, man braucht unbedingt
irgendeine Tailwind extension.
Weil sonst dreht man
durch, weil man sich nicht merken kann, was es
alles gibt. Install.
Excellent.
So. Und nun? Und nun schmeißen wir die ganze
Krempel erstmal raus, würde ich sagen.
Brauchen wir alles net.
Oh, das ist Vue.js 3
Composition
API. Hab ich noch
nix mit gemacht. Ich bin ja so richtig
Kacknoob, der
noch beim Vue 2 hängen geblieben ist.
Was sagst du zu JetBrains? Die JetBrains Sachen sind
richtig nice. Wo kommt denn das Bild
her?
Wo...
Wo kommt das Bild her? Mein Template ist leer.
Ah.
Kack wait.
Ah. Ja.
Da kommt das her.
Ich dachte, ich bin schon in der App Vue.
Hello World, Prommagard. Hier, das ist alles weg.
Alles weg. So. Excellent.
So. Alles fort.
Okay. Also. Dann
können wir mal anfangen.
Also ich hab, ich hab, ich hab
ernsthaft keine Ahnung. Also H1
Kack wait. So.
Äh. Warum ist das nicht groß?
Okay. Class. Und was gibt's jetzt?
Oh. Das sind die ganzen
Tailwind Classes. Ach du.
What the
Fuck?
Ach du Scheiße.
Wer soll ich das denn merken?
Was macht der Template Tag? Da kommt das ganz normale
HTML Zeug rein. Für eine
Vue Komponent.
Also jede, jede Komponente
in Vue besteht aus einem Style Tag,
einem Script Tag und einem Template Tag.
Und das ist alles, wenn du es nicht anders
also hier muss man eigentlich noch Scoped hinschreiben.
Das ist dann alles
nur für diese Komponente zugänglich.
Also wenn ich jetzt hier CSS reinschreibe,
dann gilt das nur hier und nicht in der anderen
Komponent und so was. Okay. Also extrem
viel. Das heißt Text. Was gibt's mit
Text? Text xs.
Oh. Ah. So
macht man das. Text
xl9
Bam. Kack wait. Alter.
Aha. Verstehe, verstehe. So funktioniert
der Kram. Gibt's auch so was wie Center?
Text Center?
Ist die CSS nicht riesig? Doch.
Deswegen haben die hier einen Guide
drin, dass wenn du das
quasi dann
mit Production
Environment bildest,
dass der den ganzen unbenutzten
Grams wieder löscht. Aktuell
ist es wohl riesig groß. Ja.
Allerdings habe ich keine Ahnung wie ich in einem
White Projekt überhaupt
ein Portbild mache.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Wie funktioniert denn das überhaupt?
NPM?
Run build? Oder so?
Tatsächlich.
Okay. Gucken wir mal wie groß
das jetzt ist.
Dist.
Okay. Das ist für eine Webseite, wo
nichts drin ist.
Doch ein bisschen groß. 3,1 MB.
Auf der anderen Seite
Facebook ist glaube ich 16 MB oder so.
Und die Leute verwenden es
trotzdem.
Aber
dann machen wir mal was die hier
reingeschrieben haben. Wenn man
bildet
Purge.
Hier.
In your tail
in your tail with config file
config purge option.
Okay.
Treeshake. Alles klar.
Nicht Monka Shake. Treeshake.
Ja.
Also
also
also tailwind
config. Wo muss das hin?
Purge.
Ich lasse jetzt einfach mal das default
drin.
Bild.
Mal gucken wie groß es jetzt ist.
Okay.
Das ist schon besser. 72.
72 K.
Und
Brotli zippt
noch weniger.
Ja.
Gzip ist aus. Heute Brotli
zippt man.
Also
wenn ihr mal klassische
Webdesign Kunst
sehen wollt.
Dann müsst ihr
dahin.
Ja. Da könnt ihr euch beispielsweise
oh.
Könnt ihr euch zum Beispiel Netzcapes
ah fuck ist das gerade kaputt.
Oh. Es ist gerade kaputt anscheinend.
Okay.
Die Webdesign ist gerade kaputt.
Aber wenn ihr mal
Oldschool Internet Zeug sehen wollt.
Dann, dann das hier ja.
Nee. Das ist anscheinend
irgendwie gerade Sign Guest Book.
Exzellent.
So.
Da könnt ihr euch mal klassisches Webdesigner
gucken.
Welches Filme würdest du empfehlen, der noch nicht viel mit
GS? A View. Das sage ich
als jemand, der von React und Angular keine
Ahnung hat. Und ich jetzt auch nicht.
Also ich versuche in letzter Zeit
immer mehr Frontend Sachen zu machen. Erstens,
weil es mir Spaß macht. Und zweitens, weil
Frontend Sachen eh nicht mehr
komplett, gar nicht mehr vorbeikommt.
Und ich habe
mit View angefangen und finde View
super. Das schöne,
was mir an View persönlich, warum ich das
auch zum Einstieg genommen habe
ist, du kannst mit View
anfangen ohne irgendwelche Build Tools.
Du kannst einfach
Du kannst einfach eine stinknormale
HTML Seite nehmen.
Script Tag rein machen.
Das hier. Script Tag rein
machen. Und dann
New View.
Muss mal ein Beispiel angucken.
Dann einfach inline im HTML
schreiben. Das heißt, du brauchst gar nichts.
Und du brauchst keine Bundler,
keine Webpack und
sonstige Dinger. Zum Anfang
ist.
Mach mal Flutter Dart Stream.
Flutter wollte ich mit...
Das steht schon seit Ewigkeiten in der
Stream Sachen drin.
Okay. Also haben die so einen...
Die haben doch bestimmt irgendwie so einen Guide.
Wow.
A Busy Feel.
Sieht das bei mir auch so aus, wenn ich
das da reinpaste? Wahrscheinlich
nicht.
Cack Wait, warum reloadet das nicht?
Ach, ich kacke nun, weil ich
beendet habe.
Post Champ?
Ey, das sieht bei mir tatsächlich so aus.
Wie bei denen. Plus das Logo fehlt noch.
Okay, nice. Also, also.
So, was kann... Was, was, was kann
man damit jetzt machen?
Ich bin unkreativ.
Wir versuchen jetzt mal...
Wir versuchen jetzt mal eine Navigationsbar
zu stylen.
Okay.
Responsive Design, bla bla.
Dark Mode. Dark Mode
ist auch immer gut.
Using Talents
is just to style your site in Dark Mode.
Ah, und
wie schaltet man dann um?
Talkling
Dark Mode.
What?
Keck...was?
Wo ist der Button zum Umschalten?
Keck, was?
Wo ist der button zum umschalten
Das ist mir zu big brain alter ah hier
Okay, das ist die ganz klassische geschichte ich setze irgendwo einfach was auf dark und dann wird es dark
Okay, okay, wir müssen jetzt mal mit was simplen anfangen was ich jetzt als als nicht design mensch auch auch machen kann
Also wir machen jetzt mal wir machen jetzt mal
Ein button der nach wie man es der navigationsleiste und ein paar buttons drin
Was gibt es eigentlich für icons haben haben die icons
ist dabei
Hero icon das habe ich schon mal gesehen das ist glaube ich von den tailwind leuten direkt dabei
Okay, search icon keck
Stonks fast
Fast chart bar was copy was copy was hatte was hat er jetzt kopiert
Ah warum ist das so fett huge huge item
Das habe ich schon mal in einem tutorial gelesen da kann man jetzt so was sagen wie höhe 6 breite
ah genau genau
Okay, so kann man das so kann man das ding jetzt kann ich kann ich jetzt auch sagen text center
Ne das funktioniert nicht warum nicht
Warum kann ich das jetzt nicht sendern und das andere kann ich sendern
Aber wahrscheinlich weil es kein text ist
Okay, ich bin absolut planlos was so was angeht
Aber das schon mal ein icon schon mal gut
Allein mittel
Ah ne das ist jetzt
Allein center gibt es nicht
Ne ne das aber mit flex wird es wahrscheinlich dann funktionieren
Genau das würde funktionieren das kann man mal ausprobieren
Flexbox champ okay klasse wie geht das jetzt
Einfach nur flex
Flex irgendwie justif, ne wie geht das just
Justify, ne äh
Oh mein ich bin kack noob was flexbox angeht
Warte mal warte mal flex die Row ist Default
Welt am rum Flex
Justify
Center ah
Center?
Ah!
Ok, ok, verstehe, verstehe.
So, da können wir jetzt unseren H1,
wenn wir das da noch rein machen, dann
das Keg-Waite.
Oh, ich bin so schlecht, was
das angeht.
Ok, ich bräuchte mal
irgendeinen...
irgendeinen, so einen
Starting-Guide.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, wir gehen es jetzt hier einfach mal
der Reihe nach durch und lesen uns das
durch, weil ich checke gar nichts.
Also wie gesagt, wir machen
mal eine Navigations-Leiste.
Wie sieht das eigentlich
mit den Fonts aus? Hat Tailwind
standardmäßig Fonts oder ist das
irgendwie ein...
Oh.
Oder ist das einfach das, was auf dem System
installiert ist?
Äh, bin ich
jetzt verwirrt? Ging das im Chrome nicht?
Man konnte doch im Chrome oder war das
nur im Firefox? Man konnte doch
dynamisch Klassen
hinzufügen,
ohne dass man sich hier reinschreiben muss,
wo man dann auch sehen konnte,
was es für
Klassen gibt.
Ne, ne, ne, das meine ich nicht. Dann hatte man hier
so ein Menü... Das da meine ich, das da meine ich.
Genau. Das hier.
Add New Class, genau.
Da kann man das nämlich, da kann man das nämlich
ausprobieren.
Da kann ich sowas sagen, wie hier
Bold oder
Text.
Sowas wie Bold.
Blue.
Boah, das ist nice. Da kann man
das nämlich dynamisch ausprobieren, hier
den ganzen Kram, ohne dass man das permanent
im Editor machen muss.
Okay, das ist
im Prinzip die Größe.
Das andere Font,
wenn es nicht... Ah!
Ich muss sagen, ich finde,
das macht auf mich den
durchdachten Eindruck. Ich habe zwar keine Ahnung
von Designsachen, aber ich glaube,
wenn man schnell was ausprobieren will,
ist das wirklich extrem
nice.
So, sagen wir mal Font,
Font,
so sagen wir mal Font,
X,
Semibolt.
Und wie geht das dann hier? Einfach
Font. Ah, genau so.
Excellent, excellent. Verstehe.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal kurz
das Tutorial hier irgendwie durchgehen.
Gut, hier erklären sie uns
jetzt, dass...
Das ist tatsächlich eine Frage,
die ich mir stelle. Warum man nicht einfach
Inline-Styles verwenden
sollte anstatt Tailwind?
Weil ich meine, ob ich jetzt das
mache oder Inline-Styles, ist doch gar kein so großer
Unterschied.
Ja genau, das habe ich mir auch gerade
gedacht. Ist das nicht einfach Inline-Styles?
Und die geben zu, es ist es. Okay, ja, das ist schon mal nice.
Da habe ich mich schon mal nicht so falsch.
Ja gut, dafür kann ich mit
Inline-Styles aber machen.
Responsive Design.
You can't use media queries in Inline-Styles.
Ach.
Ah.
Okay.
Das ist cool.
Das ist nice.
Also, wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe,
kann ich quasi die Schriftgröße
abhängig machen von der Größe
des Browser-Fensters.
Und das Ganze ohne JavaScript.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Also, wir sagen, es ist
es ist
auf MD ist es Text-Size
4.
Also ne, warte mal. Default ist Text-Size
anders.
Texts
ist 4.
Und auf Large
ist es Texts 8.
Ey, guck mal, das
ist nice. Ganz
ohne JavaScript-Gedöns.
Das ist tatsächlich, das ist wirklich
cool.
Das ist nice.
Das gefällt mir schon mal.
Das ist für die ganzen
responsive Leute ist das super.
Okay, das ist nice.
Und keine eigenen media
Queries oder so. Das ist wirklich cool.
Das hat was.
Hover, Focus and Other States.
Ach sprich, ich kann jetzt auch
direkt sowas angeben wie
Hover.
Und dann sagen wir irgendwie
Red
oder Text
Text Red
Ey, das ist nice.
Das ist
nice.
Das ist nice.
Das kann man zwar
alles auch so machen,
aber das ist auf jeden Fall ne deutlich kürzere
und knackigere Art
als das mit CSS
selbst zu machen. Ich mein, für das erste,
für das hier mit dem Text, da müsste ich
irgendwelche media Queries schreiben. Hier
Media, Screen,
Size, Blah.
Und für das zweite müsste ich quasi
ne eigene Klasse anlegen. Irgendwie
H1, Hover,
ne,
wie geht das?
Hover
und dann den Kram hier machen.
Das ist schon netter.
Warum 600? Ich vermute mal,
dass das die Intensität ist.
Ich guck, es gibt von 50.
Dann siehst du hier kaum was, dass es rot
ist. Von 50
bis, keine Ahnung,
600 oder so.
Das ist cool. Das gefällt mir. Das hat
echt was. Geht das auch mit dem
Icon hier?
Ah, guck mal, das geht doch mit dem Icon.
Das ist nice. Das gefällt mir.
Das hat was.
Das ist cool.
Okay. Also schau mal, Pluspunkt.
Schau mal, Pluspunkt.
Focus,
Inline styles, Kent,
Target, Hover oder Focus.
Okay, wir
könnten auch noch mal ein Formular machen.
Aber das ist cool.
Also da haben sie mich schon mal überzeugt, dass es
die Idee ist, was sie sich da überlegt haben.
Übrigens, der neue Pokchamp, KomodoHype,
hat gewonnen.
So, weiterer Vorteil ist,
dass ich einfach Components
extracten lasse. Okay, das stimmt.
Das können wir tatsächlich so mal ausprobieren.
We won.
Also sprich, wenn wir jetzt einen Button machen, zum Beispiel.
Button.
Der
Kegweight Button.
Nee.
Kegweight haben wir schon. Der Lul Button.
Das ist ein Button.
Das sieht natürlich ungestylt und ziemlich
crappy aus.
So, das heißt, wir können den jetzt irgendwie
anderweitig stylen.
Also sprich, Background.
Das ist ein schöner Background.
Blue 800.
Oh ja, excellent.
Border.
Round.
Wow.
Komm her.
Größe 16.
Breite 16.
Massive Button.
Okay, machen wir mal
Höhe lieber 10.
Max am Frontend.
Ja, so.
Und wie machen wir jetzt die Texts?
Was? Texts?
White.
Okay, es sieht kacke aus.
So, Outline. Wie macht man das
Outline aus?
Outline.
Outline non.
Kegweight.
Ah, das ist jetzt Focus.
Das ist jetzt Focus. Das muss ich wahrscheinlich auch
ausschalten.
Warum macht denn das hier
Zeilenumbrüche?
Focus.
Outline non.
Cool.
Das gefällt mir.
Ich war mal kurz das Icon
hier unten weg.
So.
Und wie kriege ich da als Abstand dazwischen?
Sagen wir mal, hier dazwischen
wollen wir jetzt noch Margin.
Margin Bottom.
Soll ich 10?
Ah, nice.
Okay, ich gebe zu, wirklich schöner
Button ist es nicht, aber es ist
ein Button, ja.
Nein, nein, kein neuer
Preischamp, aber das ist cool.
Okay, und jetzt können wir noch sagen
was war das? Font Bold?
Bold?
Ey komm, das geht doch jetzt schon mal
als Button irgendwie durch.
Wie mache ich da jetzt einen Click?
Wie mache ich da jetzt eine Click-Animation?
Und ab wann
macht es mal einen Seitenumbruch?
Ich meine, das ist ganz schön
lang.
Ähm.
Click?
Nee.
Hm.
Wie macht man da jetzt einen...
Fokus?
Ach stimmt, Fokus, genau.
Fokus und dann...
Was?
Wie Shadow, kommt was aus?
Aber habe ich das da hinten nicht schon?
Fokus, Outline, None.
Fokus, äh...
Ja, was ist so gut?
Was ist ein gutes Ding? Was ist das? Ring?
Was macht denn ein Ring?
Nee.
Es ist nicht Fokus.
Äh, wie, wie, wie macht man
in CSS, wie macht man in CSS
einen Button-Click?
Äh, CSS-Button-Click.
Oh.
Nee, Hoffer meine ich nicht, ich meine
wenn man draufklickt...
Fokus.
Active.
Nee.
Active?
Also kann ich...
Nee, das geht nicht.
Active?
Hm.
Nee, dass das was macht,
wenn ich draufklick.
Okay.
Tailwind-Button-Click.
Offer Fokus Other States.
Komm mal hier.
Der, aber, das sagt...
Ich will, dass der Button nicht dauerhaft
leuchtet, ich will...
Ich, ich will, dass der Button
einfach nur was macht, wenn ich draufklick.
Okay, da geht's schon los, da geht's schon los.
Der Button-Struggle ist real, Alter.
Button. Ja, so...
Wobei...
Eigentlich muss der Button nichts machen.
Das ist hover,
das ist hover.
Aber Active, Active
kann er doch nicht, oder?
Active?
Active
kann er nicht, nee, Active kann er nicht.
Ach so.
Äh.
Okay, das doch.
Nee.
Active kann man in der
Config aktivieren.
Ah, guck mal.
By Default Active Variant is not enabled
for any Core Plugins.
What?
Äh.
Moment, was?
Und was ist, wenn ich für alles aktiviert haben will?
Tailwind macht quasi, dass man kein Ziel
erst mal... anscheinend schon, ja?
Äh.
The name is Fahmy, Twitch...
Nee, kein Prime. So, Subscriptions, danke schön
für den Sub. Massive Subscription.
Also, jetzt gehe ich in meine
Tailwind-Config, das probieren wir jetzt aus.
Ich gehe in meine Tailwind-Config.
Oh.
Und dann mache ich was?
Variants
Extend Background
Color Active.
Und jetzt geht das?
Op.
Hey!
Okay, die Button,
die Kombination ist vielleicht nicht so glücklich,
was ich da gebastelt habe, aber
man kennt's.
So. Wir machen jetzt
was stylischeres.
Excellent. Massive Styleder Button machen wir jetzt.
BG Blue 500.
Sieht schon fast Bootstrap-mäßig aus, das Blau,
oder?
Das ist ein typisches Bootstrap-Blau.
Ähm.
So, und BG
Active.
Ach, jetzt kapier das.
Kann ich, kann ich es, kann ich es
einfach, kann ich das
für alles aktivieren?
Das Extend,
dass ich einfach nur sage Active?
Ohne irgendwas?
Jo, das wird nicht fun-
Ich kann es nicht für alles aktivieren.
Vielleicht, vielleicht gibt es auch ein bisschen zu viele
Klassen, hä?
Vielleicht Sternchen, sowas hier?
Oder
gequoted, gequoted?
Aha.
Okay, was ist denn da, was ist denn da ein schöner,
schöner, was sieht denn schön aus, wenn man draufklickt?
BG Blue.
Sowas hier. Ey, das ist doch ein
nicer Button.
Das ist doch ein schicker Button jetzt, oder?
Exquisite.
So, und nun?
Komm, jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Hover-Effekt.
Irgendein, irgendein Shadow.
Was kann der Button jetzt geklickt werden?
Das war's.
Das ist, es geht
nur um Style, also nur um Optik hier.
Da ist da absolut nichts funktion- Was wir als nächstes
probieren, wir machen da eine View-Klasse draus,
die wir dann, dass wir dann
überall den Button verwenden können.
Wo der Mehrwert gegenüber
Viewtify ist, da bin ich mir selbst
noch nicht so ganz sicher. Ich glaube, es gibt keinen
Mehrwert in dem Sinn. Viewtify
kann deutlich mehr.
Viewtify sind halt komplett fertige
View-Components,
die alle möglichen 30 Milliarden Funktionen
haben.
Und das ist einfach nur Design-
gedönns.
So, also das haben wir schon.
Excellent Button. Sowas machen wir noch
ein Hover-Effekt. Sag mal, macht das irgendwann
auch mal Zeilenumbruch?
Ich mein, what? Wie
lang muss denn das noch werden, dass der mal einen
Zeilenumbruch da reinmacht?
Ich mein, what the hell?
Please, Zeilenumbruch.
Kann ich selbst
Zeilenumbrüche machen?
Nee.
Was ist das für ein scheiß Formatter?
Was, alt Z?
Ach, ach, alt Z
ist das der Line-
Nee, das will ich nicht. Ich will keine
Rap an den
Zeilen haben. Ich will, dass der,
dass meine, mein,
onSave formatiert.
Never gonna Zeilenumbruch.
Das ist
irgendwie ein Formatter-
Formatter-Settings.
Settings.
So.
Format.
Formatting.
Format onSave.
Format, wo haben wir es denn?
Wo ist Javascript?
Wie?
Ach nee, Moment.
Wo ging denn das noch mal?
Pretty?
Okay.
Noji?
Wie kann man das Formatting
einstellen?
Das ist die
Settings-JSON.
Kann man das hier vielleicht
drin einstellen?
Was der, was er zum Formatieren
verwendet?
Und das
ist ja das
View-Plugin.
Prettier.
Ja?
Und wie stelle ich den
Prettier-Config ein?
Prettier.
OKS.
Äh.
Und wie stelle ich da jetzt was um?
Okay.
Here is called Prettier-Settings.
How to config Prettier.
Okay. Excellent.
Okay.
Und, und, okay. Was hatten wir
noch? Was hatten wir hier noch? Okay.
Was kann der sonst noch haben?
Pretty-HTML.
JS-Putify-HTML.
Meinetwegen ist mir eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Ich will einfach nur, dass der
nix macht, Alter.
Also manchmal ist es echt
schon hardcore
kompliziert.
Sign-Break-Class-HTML.
How to prevent.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich will es nicht
preventen. Ich will das machen.
Print with.
Okay. Was?
Wo bin ich denn hier gelandet jetzt?
Meine Fresse, Alter.
Ich checke nichts.
Ich habe die Extent.
Ja, aber irgendwas macht ja mein Formatieren
on save.
HTML Format Wrap.
Aha.
Ah.
Maximum of allowed characters per line.
Okay.
Dann gucken wir mal, ob wir es schaffen.
Über 100. Wie viel?
Wie viel sind das jetzt? Wir sind doch schon drüber.
Das sollte es eigentlich jetzt umbrechen.
Macht er aber nicht.
Juckt ihn nicht. Ist ihm egal.
Okay.
Ich bin jetzt schon
auf 100.
Okay.
Das ist krass kompliziert. Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ruby.
Vor allem, was auch nervig ist,
dass ich nicht selbst Line-Breaks
machen darf.
Okay. Das sagt man.
Dieses Setting greift anscheinend nicht.
Ich bin echt absolut ratlos,
wo ich das jetzt einstelle.
Das brauche ich auf jeden Fall.
Sonst siehst du ja gar nichts mehr.
Installiere einfach Prettier.
Okay.
Quatsch hier.
Prettier Code Formatier.
Das Ding.
Install.
Bam. Exquisite.
Exquisite.
Okay. Und jetzt gehe ich hier in die Settings
von meiner View-Extension.
Der sollte das eigentlich gecheckt haben, oder?
Oder auch nicht?
Muss ich das nochmal neu starten, oder was?
Ich hasse teilweise Frontend-Gefrickel, ey.
So.
Nein, ich will keinen Docker installieren.
Nerf nicht rum.
Also, machen tut er jetzt noch nichts.
Kann ich jetzt in den Settings
hier irgendwie einstellen, dass der
für mein View.js Zeug den Kram
verwendet?
Kebab Case.
Alles klar.
Aber... Verwendet er das
jetzt schon?
Okay.
Da verwendet er das schon anscheinend.
Kann ich jetzt in die
Prettier Settings gehen und das einstellen,
oder was?
Okay. Also.
Das sind ja 30 Milliarden Sachen.
Aber das greift nicht. Das ist weiter
als 80 Zeichen.
Ey, das ist mir zu dumm.
Das ist mir echt zu dumm. Warum gibt's denn
nicht einfach nen Setting für?
Ah, by the way, jetzt geht
formatieren und save gar
nicht mehr. Guck mal, jetzt ist formatieren und save
komplett kaputt.
Jetzt kann ich
zwar selbst einrücken, aber es
save da gar nicht mehr.
Alter, das ist so ekliges
Declay. Das kann doch nicht sein.
So, weg.
Ich zertiere mir gleich Atom, genau.
Jetzt geht's wieder.
Breakline
Class
Was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was, wie's geht.
Das kann
das kann doch echt nicht so schwer
sein, dass es nen Setting
dafür gibt, dass er nen fucking Linebreak
macht an der Stelle, wenn's zu weit, zu
breit wird, ey.
Wer hat sich das wieder ausgedacht?
Und wahrscheinlich gibt's das Setting,
aber keine Ahnung, wo das wieder steckt,
ey.
Naja, format
und save ist aktiv, aber
den juckt das nicht. Ich
hasse so rumgefrickelt, ey.
Vor allem, wenn das so absolut undurchsichtig ist.
Ich mein, das ist die Extension für View.
So, und warum gibt's da nicht nen Setting für
Linebreak?
...
Ah, hier, guck mal.
Ne, das ist hier Style?
Nein, ich will einfach, dass der mein HTML Zeug umbricht.
Du kannst 50 Billiarden Sachen einstellen, ja?
Aber es gibt kein Settings, dass der Glasdinger online breakt.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich das hier jetzt umstelle auf Pretty HTML?
So, was passiert dann?
Dann macht der irgendwie was ganz, was anderes.
Okay.
So, was passiert, wenn ich das hier umstelle auf, äh, auf none?
Macht der dann?
Nichts.
Das funktioniert schonmal.
Das ist immerhin.
So.
JS Beautify HTML.
Okay.
Ah!
Alles klar.
Er sieht zwar hässlich als Fuck aus, aber er hat's geline-breakt.
Nee, er hat's nicht geline-breakt.
Ey, du große Scheiße.
Ey, ich, ich, ich aninstall das gleich, wenn das nicht funktioniert.
Was ist Puck?
Puck ist für Leute, die HTML kacke fanden, denn HTML mit Zeilen, mit Python-Style-Einrückungen.
So Leute, noch irgendjemand, eine glorreiche Idee, wie man das einstellen kann?
Template Breakline Class.
Format.
Der Klade erkennt das, hab ich doch hier umgestellt, wenn ich das umstelle, erkennt
das doch auch.
Um so eine View-Extension, weil es es offensichtlich macht, beziehungsweise zumindest das auswählt
für formatieren, so heißt es natürlich die große Preisfrage, wo kann ich dem jetzt
sagen, wo HTML formatiert, wo sind Settings für den Standard Prettier, Prettier, Prettier,
wie auch immer.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das macht, Alter.
ES-Code, geben wir mal.
Gehen wir bloß fort mit ES-Lint, Alter, das macht es jetzt auch nicht besser.
Okay, also jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt, jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt, Big Brain, also
haben wir gemacht.
Okay, was, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, was über das Zahnrad in der Extension, welches
Zahnrad, du meinst das da, ne oder, da kommst du hier raus, da kommst du hier raus.
Da kommst du, wenn du das, wenn du das, wenn du das hier machst, da kommst du genau hier
raus.
Oh.
Prettier-rc, ich will doch keine Config in meinem Projekt anlegen, dass der den fucking
Zeilenumbruch macht.
Ich, ich glaub's net, ey.
Stimmt, weil man liegt da vielleicht schon in einem Prettier-Datei rum, Neger, äh.
Hä, ja, da komm ich doch genau, wenn ich hier drauf klicke und jetzt auf Settings oder
wie auch immer, da komm ich doch genau hier raus, da wo ich schon drinnen war.
Und da kann man nur auswählen, was der für den Prettier verwendet.
Klar sind Lime-Breaks erlaubt.
Oder, doch, klar sind Lime-Breaks erlaubt.
Okay Leute, ich hab, ich hab legit keine Ahnung, wir machen das jetzt auch nicht, weil sonst
das dauert noch ewig.
Aber, ey, man manchmal fuckt mich diese Frontend-Kram echt richtig ab, bei sowas.
Nein, ist das zu viel verlangt, eine ordentliche Option für irgendwo einzubauen, dass man sagt,
hier Lime-Breaks, easy, so, fertig, nein, kann halt so schwer sein.
Selbst wenn ich so ein Kack haben will, keine Ahnung, jedes Attribut auf eine Zeile, meinetwegen,
dann sollst du's halt machen.
Aber man erkennt halt nix.
So, jetzt haben wir zumindest meinen Huge, meinen Huge-Button am Start.
Ich wollt jetzt noch gucken, dass wenn das Ding gehovert wird.
Also, hover, ne, ne, nicht BG, also wenn das gehovert wird, dann, was sieht denn cool bei
einem Button aus?
Irgendein Shadow oder so, hm?
Kann man sowas machen?
Oh, guck mal, Massive, seht ihr das, Massive Shadow im Hintergrund, wenn man hoffert.
Man erkennt's nicht wirklich, aber, man könnte, was kann man machen, dass es cool aussieht,
wenn man hovert?
Wie macht man das in Bootstrap, oder, wie sieht das in Beautify nochmal aus, wenn man
einen Button hoffert?
Ich hab, ich hab, was so Designsachen angeht, ich bin voll blanlos, ah, ok, aber, wenn
man hovert, wird das, wird das leicht grau, oder ansonsten, wenn man klickt, wird's dann
richtig dunkel, ok.
Was html, White Space Sensitivity, also wenn das ernsthaft so heißt, White Space Sensitivity,
ne, doch, ne, was, was soll ich machen?
Hä, KS, also Extensions, html, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks, ks,
ne, also ich hab keine Ahnung, was du meinst, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format,
Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format, Format,
Ich will ja nicht, dass er die Line automatisch rappt, der soll...
Warte mal, man konnte doch irgendwo hier in die Settings so rein.
Habe ich hier eigentlich für ganzen Müll drinnen stehen?
20.
Das ist dem scheiß egal, das juckt dir nicht.
Guck mal, das ist jetzt 100.
Der macht, innerhalb von der Klasse macht er keinen Zeilenumbruch.
Das ist dem, also das, das, das schonmal nicht.
Was soll ich machen, white, nee, white space.
Es existiert nicht, was du schreibst.
So, also, ich habe keinen Plan, wie das funktioniert, ernsthaft, das leucht mir null ein.
Also, ich glaube, dass prinzipiell Zeilenumbrüche, wenn sie länger als 120 sind, sehr super,
dass die sogar funktionieren, äh, wo ist das Problem jetzt, achso, mein, das ist closed,
dass der das prinzipiell schon macht, hier mit dem Zeilenumbruch, ja, aber, oder, oder
aber man, darf man das wirklich nicht umbrechen, doch, oder, Leute, darf man, darf man, darf
man hier New Lines rein machen, oder ist das nicht erlaubt, weil sollte das nicht erlaubt
sein, wäre das echt nervig, wartet mal, kann das sein, dass das gar nicht geht, dass er
das eigentlich richtig macht, Format, none, ok, aber hier umbrechen, doch, klar, ist erlaubt,
überhaupt kein Problem, weil ich mein, gerade, gerade, wenn du da mit Tailwind 30 Milliarden
Klassen da drauf hast, dann muss, muss man das doch machen, ne, ha, prettier, prettier,
vielleicht mal, Settings, Jeson, ähm, na gut, da kann ich ja nichts einstellen, das hab
ich ja nicht installiert, als, als ich das installiert hab, ähm, war ja der Meinung,
so Format geht gar nicht mehr, die HTML Format, so, was gibt's da, enable, extra, intend,
alle HTML, was auch immer, preserve, templating, wrap attributes, ha, ok, äh, ok, macht das
jetzt was, nein, wobei, das sind ja keine Attributes, ne, was ich da hab, das sind ja
keine Attributes, das sind ja, äh, was auch immer, RayMoney, ich kann doch überhaupt
keine prettier Settings machen, ich hab doch dieses komische Plugin gar nicht installiert,
und ich seh jetzt auch nicht ein, dass ich ein Plugin installiere, dafür, dass ich meine,
meine, Klassen, Line breaken kann, das macht schonmal nix, wrap, das Format, das Format
ist bestimmt an, das ist bestimmt an, ich kann das nicht auslagern, das muss alles an
gehen, ich kann das nicht auslagern, ich kann das nicht auslagern, ich kann das nicht auslagern,
äh, ist der, aha, das ist zu, also Leute, das ist zu big brain für mich, ich bin nicht
in der Lage, den Krabi ordentlich formatieren zu lassen, das geht nicht, unmöglich, geil,
was auch immer, ich hab nicht mal es lindt installiert, beziehungsweise in dem Projekt
drinnen, aber ist schon geil, ist schon geil, also das ist, das ist, das ist next level
big brain Krabi, weil das hätte schon seinen Vorteil, weil ich mein, bei, bei, äh, bei
tailwind willst du ja total viele Klassen hier reinschreiben, und das wird ja schon
auch fast normal sein, sowas hier zu schreiben, und, oder kann doch nicht sein, Leute, ich
brauch noch, ich brauch noch nen coolen hover effect, ich brauch irgendeinen, irgendeinen
massive, was ist ein nicer, nicer hover effect, äh, border, dass man unten nen Strich drunter
macht oder sowas, was, add, apply, ach so, ja, nee, nee, das, da, da kann ich auch normales
CSS machen, so, was, was, was ist ein schöner hover, hover style jetzt, Leute, hier, big,
big brain chat design, also ich mein, hellblau wirds beim, beim klicken, nee, ach Leute,
ich weiß, was wir machen, ich weiß, was wir machen, also, active, active, Moment, wir
haben normales blue 500, active wird auf jeden Fall schonmal blue 600, ah ja, sieht schon
gleich besser aus, nee, 700, so, und hover wird bg blue 600, ach, guck hier, bam, bester
button, NA, was ein krasser button, äh, so, transition, weil, klingt wie der Original
Farben, ja, aber nur, nur wenn du runter hoverst, aber so weit wollte ich jetzt gar
nicht rumwursten, okay, wir haben nun button, okay, ich, ich wollte, ich wollte eine Navigationsleiste
eigentlich machen, um mal ein bisschen, bisschen was zu üben, ähm, okay, also, mal mal eine
Navigationsleiste, oh, alles klar, so, da kommt jetzt der button rein, das sieht schonmal
scheiße aus, okay, wir brauchen eine button component, sonst, sonst ist das absoluter
Müll, schau mal da rein, was, was genau, also für, für, für, für, da ist das Problem
mit Kommas, welches, Komma, welches Problem mit Komma, use to join classes, oh, what, what,
golden k.s., das haben wir, die haben wir, headwind, ah, der saft, der, der sortiert
das uns safe
hat er ganz schön auf wie ich will dafür nichts bezahlt
alles klar was bei punkt eins brain wind also punkt eins ist mir ist mir zu ex exquisite
ehrlich gesagt
jetzt war ernsthaft für ich soll so ein crap schreiben für zeilen umbruch was ist mit den
los soll einfach einen zeilen umbruch machen
ok wie es kaut vor ich habe noch eine idee every class online separate ja ja ja so ja
nee nee nee nee nee nein nein tss class separate line
das ist deutlich zu advanced für mich so ein einfaches setting ich hätte jetzt eigentlich
erwartet dass es kein großes akt ist dass man das so einstellen kann aber anscheinend
doch ich will ja gar nicht online ich sag mal so vier stück pro zeile oder so je nach dem wie
auch immer so dass es ein blank meinetwegen so als haben wir mein big brain button am start
der ist ja schon mal der ist ja schon mal richtig advanced so klar ist das war margin
margin vier ok perfekt
so dann machen wir jetzt meine eigene view component draus aus dieser aus diesem button
also component wir missbrauchen dazu die hello world component
button zack
ach das ist das ist diese neue neue composition geschichte habe ich keine ahnung von wie das
funktioniert ich muss ich muss da ich muss dann ein klassisches ich muss da eine klassische
view component draus machen weil ansonsten bin ich absolut nicht in der lage das überhaupt
keine ahnung habe ich noch nicht mit beschäftigt ich bin immer noch auf view 2 hängen geblieben
der wort rap funktioniert prinzipiell schon also line rap funktioniert wort rap ist jetzt
ja glaube ich nicht so das was ich haben will ich will es ja nur für classes haben gdj z
martin 19 monate so viel das ist ja hyper subscript so ich mache mal da eine normale
view component draus weil ich sonst dazu zu nur mich für bin gibt es hat es eigentlich
hier hat es da irgendein irgendein makro für a ja hier excellent kann ich den kram rausschmeißen
haupts habe ich jetzt gemacht zehn monate da ich für den sub mark ldm n hütsch subscript
wie heißt unsere component einfach nur big brain button template so und dann ja text
ok das ist jetzt keine sondern ich massive brain component aber immerhin data wie ging
es jetzt noch mal return nee aus dem kopf alter return so war das glaube text gucken
wir mal kurz ob das funktioniert ach nee ich brauche ja den propp propp propp propp
text data brauchen wir gar nicht so jetzt haben wir unseren button gut wunderbar mehr
brauchen wir glaube ich nicht alles klar achso umbenennen müssen wir das noch hello world
heißt nicht mehr hello world sondern big brain button view excellent excellent so jetzt
können wir nämlich den button weg machen ah nee import muss was noch big brain button
text hello text ok jetzt muss ich den kram noch importieren wie ging das jetzt hier
subscript stopp setup muss man dann weg machen an der stelle import ach du große was da kram
denn components big brain button big brain button oh nee punkt view habe ich jetzt irgendwas
vergessen warum nicht angular kannst du auch fragen oder warum nicht jquery ach nee warte
mal setup war das reicht das nicht so war das nicht alles was er machen musste ach ja
stimmt stimmt stimmt kommt aber das kann ich auch nicht total bescheuern was habe ich
denn vergessen das ist irgendwie u3 geschichte wahrscheinlich was export default keine dinger
was ernsthaft exquisite chat der chat ist wieder massive brain hier ok warum meckert
er überhaupt dass es not used wird natürlich wird es just ich war ja unten ich aber ok
jetzt haben wir den button drinne perfekt so jetzt können wir nämlich alles mögliche
reinschreiben an text was wir wollen jetzt haben wir ok jetzt können wir hier 1 2 3
4 buttons machen dann müssen wir gucken dass die ok jetzt kann ich meine flexbox skills
ausprobieren warte mal padding jedes element geht nicht na also flex so und jetzt kommt
man was justify center und jetzt space between oder irgendwie sowas nee alter flex space
ach du große kacke wie ging das jetzt nochmal between content just nee doch nee ich will
aber space man konnte doch space irgendwie dazwischen machen das was macht das space
ah yes ich habe keine ahnung was es jetzt macht aber anscheinend da kann ich mir flexbox
gedönste auch sparen oder ja wobei sonst besser eine exzellente navigations leiste hier besser
also viel viel nicer geht es ja ganz schön start und jetzt margin left 2 ok ist der chill
aber funktioniert ok jetzt haben wir unsere tollen buttons also das ist der button für
home das ist der button für twitch was auch immer ich schreibe jetzt irgendwas rein youtube
und das hier ist das impressum natürlich was sonst so der ist der ist nicht agile genug
der button der der kapiert es nicht der sagt da müssen wir die feste feste breite rausnehmen
wahrscheinlich ok kann man haben mindestens breite min 16 oder so wow monkaS wie kann
ich ihm dann sagen dass ich mindestens mindestens 16 haben will jetzt ist überhaupt ok wir machen
wir machen es big problem wir machen einfach alles größer dann passt wieder oh nee das
geht nicht mehr weh was ist das größte wie ins manch bäm perfekt wirklich responsive
ist es nicht ok huge navigations leiste ok so wie krieg ich da jetzt icons rein moment
icons war das hero icon haben die sowas wie youtube im pressum video ist das egal video
tag ich meine da kann ich bestimmt auch material design icons rein machen es dürfte wahrscheinlich
kein problem sein wie kriege ich denn jetzt den moment wie kriege ich denn da jetzt den
das sieht mega beschissen aus wie kriege ich denn das jetzt auf die gleiche zeile ok ok
nice exzellent exzellent das sieht doch gar nicht so schlecht aus plus plus die gesamtbreite
ein bisschen bisschen bisschen hier was gibt es da noch 28 exzellent so jetzt müssen natürlich
noch darauf dafür sorgen dass das dynamisch dynamisch geht das icon und zwar wir könnten
jetzt letztendlich will ich mir eher das css angucken und nicht das view zeug wir können
den slot machen und dann das icon aus dem parent element da irgendwie in rein monka
das icon slot nee aber wie ging das jetzt noch mal slot und jetzt konnte man noch hier
quasi sagen ich jetzt diese ganze view cs geschichte noch ja genau kann man das hier
an der stelle rein packen gibt es das nicht noch ein bisschen schöner diese icons ich
habe keinen bock hier immer den svg rein zu copy pasten immer das hero icons github gibt
es nicht schon fertig fertige css klassen ich meine ich könnte auch ich könnte auch
einfach die mde icons verwenden das wird auch funktionieren aber weil das jedes mal
reinkopieren ist doch ja so was da genau das wird was anderes ok was was github mde icons
fertig einfach included und gut ist da kenne ich die eigens für da github wo gab es den
kram zum download noch mal macht es sonst immer wie über die über die cli da ist das
hier npm install mde font gucken wir das funktioniert ja da so ging das genau also erstmal das halbe
internet wieder installieren und dann import mde font css alles klar viele deiner freunde
benutzen den preisschamp excellent das finde ich nice jetzt muss was wie importieren wo
muss man das jetzt importieren in main meint die musik ist vorbei ich brauche ein bisschen
mario kart musik ok wenn ich mich hier verschreibe dann kann das nicht importieren das ist gut
da weiß ich dass es funktioniert so also dann machen wir jetzt mal hier einen icon rein
wie hat man den kram jetzt noch mal verwendet weil einfach nur mde irgendwas ging wahrscheinlich
nicht so ne oh ne warte mal wie fuck wir hatten das jetzt noch mal funktioniert ich hab das
noch nie außerhalb hier von und example please css will doch einfach nur icons haben
npm install ja so so schlau bin ich auch schon gewesen und jetzt example please sagt mir
doch einfach wie es funktioniert oh ne ne das will ich nicht aufmachen das kack mein browser
wenn ich das aufmache ok kann man jetzt einfach mal gucken wenn ich sie einfach sagt ne ne
das will ich nicht das da will ich haben mde ahja mde account warum kann er das icon jetzt
nicht anzeigen das ist so ein rotz das kann er zu kompliziert sein alles heute warum zeigt
jetzt nicht einfach einen icon an der stelle ultra komplexer shit wieder also warum kann
ich jetzt nicht einfach sagen diff class mde alert oder sowas bäm warum ist er hier was
das warum ist das hier nicht am start anzeige ist raus warum geht das warum geht das hier
ein hat ursprünglich icon noch dabei machen oder so was material icons ne das das sind
nur wenn man die oft die offiziellen google dinger verwendet klob das kann das mal kopiiert
ich glaube das sind nur für die offiziellen google dinger ja sieht man mal die sachen
sind nicht so einfach wie sie wie sie aussehen dass ich meine es muss ja so easy sein dass
man absolut keine erklärung dazu braucht learn more war das so aber man musste einfach
mde da vorschreiben da ist es da haben wir das icon sehr schön hat jemand eine ahnung
wie der parameter das dann granate in mw2 heißt möchte die restriktion na klar wer
weiß sowas nicht ne ne keine ahnung so jetzt haben wir unser poggers icon drin class margin
left zwei ne nicht margin margin right zwei so schick sehr gut home gibt es dafür schöne
das ist doch schick das ist doch nice kann man jetzt auch sagen h10 h10 oh ne das das
da blickt dann immer durch jetzt wenn man das icon an sich größer macht ok nice das
heißt jetzt haben wir eine eigene button component gebaut das finde ich schon mal cool oder
können wir jetzt eikens rein dingsen ok schön so was kann man was kann man auch interessantes
machen damit also ja hat das ding youtube youtube youtube gibt es gibt es den twitch
eigen hey es gibt so twitch eigen was was heißt ein impressor auf englisch heißt es
nicht imprint oder sowas impressum englisch doch imprint gibt es nicht document wenn man
richtig schreiben kann dokument ja irgendwie sowas beim fall document muss ja nicht schön
sein aber so excellent nachbar alda viel stylischer kann es ja immer sein so und jetzt und super
not responsive aber immerhin die überschrift die überschrift ist super responsive guckt
euch mal wie responsive die überschrift ist massive responsiveness huge puge puge responsiveness
was programmierst du ich guck mir nur tailwind an ich programmier gar nix ich stelle wieder
fest dass ich was design angeht einfach nur sacker alda massive sack was design angeht
ok also aber es ist schon mal eine super super poggers nachbar die man manchmal übrigens
tracken droppen kann kann man so selectable oder so ausschalten das select ah cool kann
ich den kram hier auch nämlich nicht mehr sinnlos sinnlos anklicken also das ist schon
mal nice das gefällt ok youtube impress haben die vielleicht legal oder sowas gut so dann
machen wir jetzt auch ok also nachbar was was ist denn heutzutage noch in der cool nachbar
drin ein settings icon oder settings icon ist dann auch drin text gibt's net yep cock
indonesien bach genau ok schick ich meine da ist ein bisschen fett der ist jetzt ist
jetzt ein bisschen ein bisschen sehr sick aber wie weg wir machen wie kann ich eine mindest
breite wobei ich will gar keine mindest breite warte mal das passt schon wir waren mindest
breite der settings button muss kleiner sein auf jeden fall da war mir nämlich einfach
so icon wir bauen jetzt beautify nach im endeffekt icon so und dann sagen wir nämlich hier wenn
wie ging das noch mal klasse wenn wenn icon dann wenn icon gesetzt ist dann breite so
und ansonsten breite keine ahnung b 6 ok ah moment umgedreht umgedreht ah ok so und
jetzt kann ich bei meinem button hier unten sagen das icon eigentlich icon ah guck funktioniert
echt auch wenn ich einfach so icon setze vielleicht nicht es sieht es sieht beschissen aus
jutsch jutsch ach so das liegt an meiner margin ok ok hey immerhin versiv die sein skills
aufwarten als aus dem tier sieht fast so gut aus wie die magenta klaut nach bar ok nice
ist das nicht ist das nicht stylish du du du du du du du du du du du eins kann man zumindest
es sieht weder nach bootstrap aus noch sieht es nach nach material design aus es sieht
nach nach wo bloß dies sein aus so und wie kann ich dem flex zeugs jetzt sagen dass
der dieses icon ans ende pushen soll das geht doch irgendwie klasse flex item item nee ach
du große scheiße das ging doch irgendwie flex item at end ja genau last last flex wie
wie sage ich dem das jetzt das ist manjaro tailwind flex last item end items end oh jetzt
wirds jetzt wirds big brain align self flex end ja gut das gibt es da aber end play self
end ha ha nein denied oh ein ein moment weil
man ist jetzt ist die jetzt nur bis da oder geht über die komplette zeile bg rats jede
komplette zeil ok wie wie wie pack ich das ding jetzt an ans ende ist wieder äußerst
äußerst komplex justify self end gut haben die da haben die da irgendwie ein beispiel
für wie ich davon absolut kein plan hab ne justify ja gut so so schlau war ich auch
schon ich will alles ich will alles links haben und eins am ende flex last item end
was eigentlich margin left auto what ne oder right nope das muss doch mit flex das muss
doch gehen ich meine was ich machen kann ist absolut und dann right aber das ist glaube
ich nicht sehen und zweck der übung gehen tut es aber sondern ich geil finde ich da
so also leute ihr müsst ja schon zugeben also das ist eine äußerst nice navigationsleiste
oder also eine einer der besten definitiv die leiste navigationsleiste das sieht so scheiße
am start die sein gott ja sowas will ich haben genau es ist wie in line styles ja sagen sie
ja auch selbst aber wisst ihr wisst ihr was das für ein vorteil hat wenn ich mich damit
ein bisschen beschäftige vielleicht werde ich dann ein bisschen besser was design und
css angeht weil ich habe aktuell halt absolut kaum plan davon ja und für ein bisschen front
entstellt kann es auf jeden fall nicht schaden margin top auch 10 jawoll beste beste nachbar
aller zeiten vielleicht sollten wir beim eiken die höhe auch noch anpassen wobei die höhe
muss bei allen gleich sein sonst sieht es kacke aus oder aber wir machen das noch ein
ticken breiter wir sagen sogar 10 ja das sieht besser aus oder quadratisch oder so das sieht
auch tatsächlich ganz nett aus jetzt machst du meine hausarbeit in er mit tensor flow
bis freitag ich habe noch nicht eine sache in er gemacht und mit tensor flow auch nur
sehr am rande für meine things hier objekterkennung ok so ist auch ganz hübsch also haben wir
das erste am start guck mal ich finde es immer noch geil wie massive responsive die überschrift
ist huge responsive überschriften was passiert denn wenn es zu klein wird hier gar nichts
dann schreckts einfach ich habe wir könnten ja sogar sagen normale größe ist vier mittlere
größe ist sechs und latsch größe ist text acht so pass mal auf bäm bäm komm mal hier
stufe zweite stufe ist das huge responsive huge ultra responsive ok was was können wir
jetzt noch schönes einbauen button haben wir navigationsleiste haben wir ne karte sowas
hier oh ja oh ja leute dings hier denn ja für den für den content für den eigentlichen
für den eigentlichen content content so so ne karte mit mit mit mit schatten und sowas
ich hab von er keine ahnung aber aber ich kann kobold habt ihr hab ich euch hier letzten
weihnachten bewiesen was für geiler kobold hacker ich bin also was kann man da jetzt
machen also erstmal krebs margin bis sie abstand abstand margin margin all zwei margin
zwei ja ok gut so shadow kann man da jetzt kann man da jetzt innen also voll volle breite
volle breite volle höhe bg das was man sieht ok das ist schon mal keine volle höhe
warum ist die margin nicht rechts warum ist die margin nicht rechts was ist das
wird das überschrieben weil ich volle breite gesagt habe oder so ist aber doof ach ne moment
da macht es auch so ja ok ok ok mx ich will ich will es ja überall schon ok so padding
noch mal vier padding vier reicht ein ne so so wie kriege ich denn da jetzt wie kriege
ich denn da jetzt den schatten dahinter shadow hat das jetzt den schatten ja mit klein oder
ja das hat man erkennt das nur kaum aber color oder sowas kacke aus ok border border
oder black so funktioniert das schon mal nicht das ist die mario kart super Nintendo ghost
ok mit border geht das schon mal nicht border border aha jetzt hast du was wie border zwei
border drei die musik ist mal richtig wacke als border ach hier border was rounded oh jetzt
jetzt wird zu big brain was rounded rounded ah ne moment das ist black wie sage ich jetzt
die größe von dem ach so einfach border vier zum beispiel border zwei ok verstehe wann
kommt das da ihm ja das muss auch noch sein so wie wir machen so eine ordentliche karte
also wir brauchen erst mal eine überschrift also h2 class text 4 aber ich bin ja ich bin
ja lernt sich das beschissen aus hier content so wie kriege ich denn da jetzt wie sieht
wie sieht eine schöne karte schöne content dings aus wie sieht denn sowas aus wie sieht
die beautiful aus die sieht doch ganz hübsch aus so im prinzip besteht diese karte nur
aus nem schatten dahinter ne sonst nix titel titel text ok button button brauchen wir noch
brauche big brain buttons brauche wir noch achso das ist den falschen button den ich
klasse margin right 2 ok aber kein impressum kein impressum sondern text keine ahnung safe
und cancel wir fällt jetzt da grad nix anderes ein zu so disk heißt das ding safe
also welche software benutze genau das das ist das ist visual studio code allerdings
je nachdem für er habe ich keine ahnung also ich verwende rider ich ich verwende rider
für c-sharp backend gedöns und visual studio code für frontend kram content safe ok das
ding gibt es auch den material design eiken extension material design eiken vias code
intellisens jetzt bestimmt akuma da excellent das da material design eikens intellisens
da kann ich dann quasi schreiben mdi das ist praktisch das brauche install exquisite
ja ja das für die feier das kann das weiß ich so und jetzt kann wir sagen mdi ach hier
kann das ja das ist ja cool komm mal jetzt zeigt er auch sogar das eiken hier als vorschau
an das ist cool also mdi und jetzt kann ich so was wie safe das ist tatsächlich nice ok
das gefällt mir das hat was aber das ist cool so jetzt müssen wir natürlich dem button
noch irgendwie eine andere background color beibringen können wir können unserer button
klar den big brain button den müssen wir jetzt noch andere andere background color beibringen
können also cancel cancel ist ich glaube das hieß einfach cancel genau sieht sieht aber
richtig dumm aus das heißt einfach nur cancel genau exquisite das eiken kommt auch weg hässlich
aus sehr schön so wie könnte man jetzt so diese diese card schick machen also die haben
im prinzip ja nichts anderes als ein titel titel habe ich auch subtitel brauchen wir jetzt
netz wie macht man den text überhaupt grau aber p leute wir brauchen den lorem ipsum generator
ganz wichtig gibt es auch bestimmt ja ja genau exquisite das ganz ganz muss bacon bacon
ipsum ok gibt es das auch kann kann er das kann er das so schon
tatsächlich kommt man da muss man gar nichts mehr selbst machen braucht man gar keine extension
für kannst du nicht mit der musik konzentrieren klar das ist ultra ultra nice entspannende
musik also content ich mein hey man muss mal sagen ja die seite sieht jetzt nicht wirklich
wahnsinnig schön aus aber die sieht auch nicht ultra hässlich aus oder ich meine es gibt
doch durchaus schlimmeres so funktionabel ok wie können wir denn jetzt da irgendwie
ordentlichen schatten hin machen tailwind shadow dass es nicht plaudet genau so sieht
es aus box shadow ja habe ich doch shadow und shadow md ja aber die color vom shadow brauchen
wir noch hier ok also es kann in shadow shadow genau ich kenne ich überhaupt nicht shadow
also man erkennt aber es ist doch kaum kaum das liegt an meinem hintergrund wahrscheinlich
doch jetzt erkennt man es aber es liegt an meinem hintergrund dass man das nicht so richtig
erkennt border kleiner man man man man erkennt schon border brauche man übrigens border
brauche übrigens gar nicht aber rounded darf sein das ist durchaus in ordnung doch doch
guck mal jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt steht das so richtig raus wir müssen jetzt nur noch
die gesamte seite einfach ein bisschen bg black ne bg grey grey ich glaube das geht nicht
an der stelle muss dann den diff drumherum machen komplett hier klas bg kumow ein ja
ich glaube da müssen wir main moment in der wo wo ist das body element drinne war das
versteckt body body hier index da ist wahrscheinlich ja jetzt moment warum ist der hintergrund
jetzt auch ach weil sich das vererbt nur rules danke schön für den sub das vererbt sich
der hintergrund ok also brauchen wir dann hier sowas wie einfach bg bg white ok das
sieht jetzt gar nicht so kacke aus das kann man sogar halbwegs lassen i b2 dankeschön
mit dem prime sub massive brain subscription hier wieder genau ich mache das ebay design
neu easy so wir machen jetzt zwischen nafbar und unten margin bottom machen wir nur ein
bisschen platz also ich muss sagen für das dass ich so ultra sacke das das das sieht
besser aus als wir das vorgestellt haben ja so jetzt müssen wir noch die buttons irgendwie
ein bisschen anpassen und zwar also ich kopiere jetzt beautify einfach mal so icon haben wir
ansonsten haben wir noch zur auswahl das können wir noch machen was was ist das gibt es
auch für den button typ text ne nicht text transparent oder sowas keine ahnung weiss
wie ich es denn soll das stimmt das steht den hintergrund weg mache sieht aus wie ein
cookie banner ja tatsächlich oder oder oder weil weil was jetzt ganz cool wäre wenn ich
jetzt noch einen button hätte wo einfach wo einfach nur ein text steht so für cancel
ich kopiere das mal ich zeige euch schon was ich meine dass wir jetzt einfach sowas hier
haben das da steht cancel und allerdings komplett ohne background dann erkennt man es ja gar
nicht mehr da muss man die die schrift sowas hier die schrift machen wir jetzt einfach
so die idee heute die idee dass das gefällt mir das nice pock das sagt aber aber das gefällt
mir das nice das sind safe button da hast du den safe button und den cancel das machen
die beispielsweise bei digital außen und bei keine ahnung bei all bei vielen seiten
mache ich das so dass der der wichtige button ist ein button und der cancel button ist so
ist so so da das finde ich eigentlich gut es war nicht so auffällig springt nicht so
springt nicht so sehr ins auge ok ist es jetzt auch responsive ja so so ein bisschen bis
auf die navigations leiste die ist nicht wirklich responsive aber da bin ich zu dumm ich weiß
nicht wie ich die wie ich die besser responsive machen sollen weil irgendwo müssen die texte
ja hin common sense sagt er findet das design schön und clean ich würde es noch nicht
mal so weit gehen und design nennen ich habe etwas zusammengepasst ok aber es ist auf jeden
fall besser als die xd bootstrap seite lass sie untereinander rutschen ja da weiß ich
erstens nicht wie es geht und zweitens glaube ich sieht das so unkontrolliert ziemlich doof
aus eigentlich müsste die navigations leute ich habe die big brain idee ever wir machen
den text weg wir machen den text weg wenn es einfach zu klein wird wir machen nur auf
die ikons das ist die idee es soll doch die frage wie wir das machen also sprich wenn
es zu klein wird dann dann machen wir nur noch die ikons in den button big brain ja
poggers so machen wir das aber ich weiß nicht wie ich das mache ok warte mal ok ok big
brain time nutz hotel mit fürs nächste projekt vielleicht ich habe keine ahnung ich will
voll zu mir einfach mal angucken ok ok moment ich erkenne ja wieder nix weil ich hier nichts
nichts leiten kann also also das ist alles ok wir müssen jetzt
das ist easy das ist easy einfach gucken ja diff das ist easy as fuck ist das leute easy
as fuck pass mal auf pass mal auf wenn es wenn es small ist klasse wenn es small ist
dann display oder non wie mache ich das weg tailwind display non ne burger menu bin ich
zu dumm für lock hitten hitten hitten ist es hitten
sollte das nicht genau umgedreht sein
versteht das irgendjemand wenn es small ist ist es da
ja ist auch ist ok
aber sollte es normalerweise nicht angezeigt werden
so ganz verstanden habe ich immer noch nicht
aber aber prinzipiell ist es so richtig so und jetzt muss ich einfach nur noch sagen
dass die breite also bei sm wird dann das dahinter dahinter ausgelöst ja aber es ist
die fault hitten es ist die fault hitten aber die fault ist es da obwohl es die fault hitten
sein müsste weil das hier ist ja nicht sm oder bedeutet das nicht bei der kleiner sondern
größer sm dann würde das nämlich sind ist das das ist das hier kein kleiner sondern
in implizierten größer als ach so verstehe verstehe mobile first exzellent so jetzt ist
natürlich die große preisfrage wie kriege ich jetzt gebacken dass die breite angepasst
wird also sage ich sm
moment sm breite
ok das das das funktioniert schon mal wenn es klein ist dann ist nur
also wenn es größer ist wenn es größer ist 32 haben ok das passt aber aber nicht
bei eiken überschreibt er das jetzt net das ist nicht bootstrap nein das ist eigene konstruktion
der safe button ist was eigenes ja also prinzipiell oder ich bin ultra verwirrt was was mache
ich hier überhaupt ich bleib nicht mehr durch ok scheiß mal auf das eiken erstmal das funktioniert
ja fast schon fast was wie wie sage ich ihm dann die größe für sm also das ist alles
über sm oder sage ich ihm die folgt die folgt ist 10 ok aber das sieht das sieht das sieht
das schon mal besser aus guck dir mal guck dir mal fast fast guck mal guck mal das ist
gar nicht mal so schlecht das es geht nicht geht in die richtige richtung ja es geht
in die richtige richtung dass das hier hinten stimmt nicht aber das ok es ist fast es ist
fast schon fast schon fast fast gut ja aber die idee funktioniert schon mal hast du schon
einen friseurtermin ne habe ich noch nicht aber es wird mal wieder zeit aber es wird
es wird es wird echt mal wieder zeit by the way meine meine buttons sind natürlich kaputt
weil das sich jetzt nur auf den auf die nafbar eigens bezieht nicht auf den button da unten
deswegen mache ich den button da unten mal kurz da raus
ich will jetzt die nafbar ordentlich hinkriegen wie kriege ich das gebacken dass der das
ist ja alles so schön und gut aber ich will dass das eiken immer überschreibt das ganze
also wenn ein eiken gesetzt ist wie kann ich ihm jetzt sagen dass das vorrang hat vor
dem ok das ist das ist glaube ich jetzt nicht so nicht so nicht so easy
smw 10 beim eiken man ist da stimmt stimmt man kann nee nee nee nee nee nee nee das
bringt nichts wenn ich das beim eigen macht bringt nichts dann ist der button ja trotzdem
so breit ich muss moment ich weiß was ich machen muss warte mal das ist schwachsinn
was ich hier gemacht habe das stimmt nicht was ich hier gemacht habe so muss das sein
ok jetzt bleibt es nämlich immer gleich groß
und default ist es w10 ha exzellent guckt euch das an massive responsiveness hier massive
responsiveness
ui guru ich mach mein mein jude me und und sonst was kurs gibt's morgen aber das ist
nice das ist cool das gefällt mir richtig gut ok das hier sieht sackig aus aber ganz
ehrlich wenn die graben so klein macht hat echt gelitten
kommen sogar seht ihr die wie wie wie massive responsiveness überschrift ist hier schon
keck weight keck weight keck weight keck weight größer keck weight fett
poggers mass
was gibt's eigentlich noch für breakpoints tailwind breakpoints vielleicht ist ja sm
gar nicht so dass das passende breakpoints also smmd vielleicht sollte ich es besser
auch ab md machen
nicht quatsch quatsch nicht ab md ab gibt's noch was kleineres ne sm ist das kleinste
alles klar sind zwar ein bisschen viel platz aber was willst du machen
hat immer eine bessere idee wie man das ein bisschen kleiner hinkriegt aber das ist ok
weil das könnte wobei es bringt gar nichts guck mal hier wirds anstoßen hier wirds
hier wirds anstoßen das muss der das muss der machen cool
ich mein man könnte die batten buttons ein bisschen größer machen
ja moment jetzt ist natürlich das andere auch
der wave warum hat es das so nicht funktioniert ach so warte mal ich so machen uns aha exquisite
so also es ist 10 wenn es ein icon ist oder es ist sagen wir mal 14 ja cool nice oh das
ist das ist schick guck mal jetzt sind nämlich die icons ein bisschen größer und man könnte
die icons leute jetzt jetzt noch massive brain idee wir machen die icons größer wenn es
minimiert wenn das so jetzt machen wir die icons noch größer weil das ist ja der text
weg magst du webapp frameworks und css format ich war grad so vertieft in meine kreation
es gibt für es gibt für view eine bootstrap component library glaub das hier das ist quasi
view components in bootstrap style das ist dann quasi sowas wie viewtify nur in bootstrap
look gibt ja noch mehr gibt ja noch bulma und bouffi bouffi bouefi oder wie man das
ausspricht und es gibt noch quasi und es gibt es gibt ja gibt ja zig zig zig dinger
die irgendwelche css css sachen nehmen und daraus view components im prinzip ist es
ja das gleiche was ich hier auch mache ich habe hier so eine komische button component
gebastelt mit tailwind styling und das finde ich nice wie das guck mal guck mal wie das
exzellent wie responsive es ist ja massive responsive ich freue mich gerade richtig
selbst wenn man kann mich auch mit einfachen sachen erfreuen soll jetzt noch jetzt und
jetzt noch eikens größer machen und jetzt noch eikens größer wie machen wir eikens
größer wenn wenn das klein ist da müssen wir doch eigentlich nur und die eikens sind
ja im endeffekt da das jetzt ein bisschen doof kann man die eikens so vielleicht welch
das ist i3 wm moment wie kriege ich moment ich muss es mal kurz mit inline zs probieren
ob das ob das überhaupt funktioniert font size ah nice nice ok das wird das das wird
das machen also sage ich dann jetzt klas font und der text war es text xl und das sagen
wir nur warte mal es ist es ist ein moment moment wir wollen default mäßig text lg
oder so haben dass es gut gut allein aussieht oder text md text m gibt es noch sm base base
wollen wir normal haben das sieht das ohne ohne was auch so aus so text base und dann wenn das moment
umgedreht umgedreht dass das invert im kopf muss ich noch muss ich noch
die eikens werden größer zack excellent exquisite das ist doch schick
guckst du dir sonst nur die doku ich guck mir gar nichts an ich habe das zum ersten mal
heute verwendet und ja ich habe im prinzip nur da reingeguckt und ein bisschen getting
started man merkt euch habe auch keinen plan guck mal wie die unterschiede sobald sobald
es hier verschwindet von von groß ding von von großer nafbar zu klein werden die buttons
größer die eikens so ist das doch sehr schick sehr sehr schick exzellent exzellent die dinger
sind gar nicht richtig allein kann man da machen dass die richtig allein sind wobei
ich glaube einfach nur das twitch sagt nur das twitch eiken ist kacke guck mal der rest
der rest ist gut allein das twitch eiken sagt das gefällt mir das gefällt mir so wie kriege
ich jetzt noch einen margin rein zwischen den text und dem eiken margin right zwei
und das an den ssm ich weiß leute ich bin gerade ein bisschen am durchdrehen ich glaube
man man merkt aber ich bin echt begeistert davon wie gut das funktioniert zu viel margin
findeste margin eins heute was besser ein margin oder zwei margin oder vielleicht sogar
drei margin oder vier margin eins eins ernsthaft ich persönlich finde zwei schicker aber chat
mein eins fünf ja fünf exzellent warum nicht gleich 16 ok 1 margin 1 ja so habe ich jetzt
gemacht groß dicke finger moment jetzt stimmt mein fack jetzt stimmt das eiken nicht mehr
kann ich das jetzt irgendwie noch geschickt geschickt um schiffen margin nur auf text
anwenden ja das können wir machen das eine gute idee also das war quasi sagen hier margin
left aber so ganz stimmt das immer noch nicht ach so na der weiß ja nicht der weiß ja nicht
dass wir den text hier auspländen der macht die plände das nicht mit aus er ist dazu zu
nubig für ich hätte eigentlich gedacht wenn es ausgeblendet ist das margin auch weg aber
ok ist es anscheinend nicht das plan er hinten ist das planen sagen die zumindest haben die
gesagt hinten display na da dass ich das translated zu kann man mal gucken man sieht man sieht
äußerst viel jetzt richtig richtig massiv viel zu sehen hier gar nicht dabei moment
das funktioniert ja auch mit dem hinten wenn wenn es hinten ist dann geht das weg ne ne
das stimmt schon aber das problem ist dass es ja normalerweise gar wenn es kleiner wird
auch kein text hat das heißt ich müsste hier eigentlich noch big brain abfrage rein machen
ob da ob da quasi ob das eit ob das ein eiken only ist also im prinzip muss man jetzt noch
mal so was hier machen jetzt kann ich anderes ein was ist ein eiken wenn eiken dann nix und
ansonsten hat er jetzt für schmerzen also ansonsten ist margin left eins guckt jetzt passt das zwar
nicht schön aber funktioniert so excellent excellent so was was könnte man noch was
könnte man noch die sein wo wir gerade im design gott modus sind er vf text ne text ist ja immer
gesetzt der planet text und dynamisch aus je nachdem wie breit das ist also in text hier steht immer
was drin dark mode war da bin ich zu lauprank glaube ich für den dark mode ok das probieren
jetzt noch aus dark mode bottom navigation zum futter futter futter wie heißt das überhaupt
futter futter futter ich spreche mal das richtig aus futter futter pronunciation futu was
moment ich habe ja kein kein sound achtung puta futter futter futter futter amerikan
kokona futter futter perfekt futter futter gefällt mir am besten kokona style aber beste
futter futter futter ok da war jetzt ein futter machen wir jetzt ich bin begeistert über meine
responsive skills hier ach so moment hier die eigens unten sehen noch ziemlich sackig aus ne
ich habe jetzt auch fack ich habe jetzt keinen bock meinen button noch anzupassen dass ich ihn
ja der button geht jetzt natürlich nicht weil der button denkt er ist in der nav bar
ok aber das das das können wir das können wir ändern da machen wir jetzt hier noch so
noch ein prop genau wie nenne ich das denn naf nee keine ahnung static wobei static
ist schon doppelt belegt wenn static gesetzt ist wenn static gesetzt ist dann macht er diesen
ganzen krempel nicht dieser ganze responsiveness macht er dann einfach nicht so also sprich wo
ist hier unser responsive responsive kram einmal durch ane da muss hier noch ein if ins if machen
no no no das oh nee nee nee nee nee das mache ich nicht da müsste ich hier noch ein if reinbauen
also sprich mal gucken ob wir das inline hinkriegen was war static und das funktioniert gar nicht oder
alles preserved ok lull heißt es einfach nur dann lull hier noch noch funktioniert alles
ha fast fast fast ok das ist mega hässlich gerade aber prinzipiell funktioniert es mal
ich weiß gar nicht ob ich jetzt mal was machen muss aber ok das ist massiv abartig
nee moment was habe ich jetzt gemacht ich blickte mal durch leute massive clean code also wenn das
nicht clean code ist leute dann weiß ich auch nicht was das hier sein ach so das liegt an dem
hinten an dem hinten liegt das also sprich eigentlich müsste ich jetzt sagen kann ich
sowas doppelt hier machen da müsste ich jetzt da müsste ich jetzt also quasi sowas hier oh nee
da kann ich die kenne ich die sonntags nicht für die sind wie ist die richtige sonntags
oh fuck das krieg ich das weiß ich das kriege aus dem kopf hin die ist dann die richtige
sonntags für dass ich das nur mache wenn das true ist irgendwie klammern oder so war das
irgendwas mit klammern drum herum ja das da das da meine ich das das da meine ich also ich
war ja fast richtig fast richtig moment ich blickte ich blickte immer durch ok wie klas
das da das muss man bestimmt quaten dass das funktioniert und jetzt icon
ja
Kegweight. Ne ne das funktioniert schon. Not icon? Ah. Not icon.
Ah, yes. Sehr gut, okay.
Okay, das funzt. So, was, Moment, jetzt hab ich schon ganz vergessen, was ich machen wollte.
Ich wollte den save button safen.
So, okay, wie, wie könnte man, wie könnte man das jetzt machen?
Der save button soll da bleiben, wenn LUL gesetzt ist. Also sprich, wenn, kann man das jetzt, wie macht man da mehrere Sachen? Mit Komma?
Scheint.
Wenn, not, LUL, wenn, wenn, LUL, äh, wait a minute, nutzt das jetzt?
Also eins von beiden müsste ja funktionieren jetzt.
Kann man das nicht so hinterländer schreiben?
Okay, ich bin dazu blöd für.
Da muss noch hidden mit rein. Echt jetzt?
Und hidden ist doch eigentlich default dann. Ach ne, Moment, sonst ist es immer hidden.
Ah, ja. Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Exquisite. So ist das. Es ist massive clean code. Clean coders hassen diesen Trick.
Aber es funktioniert.
Warum ist jetzt eigentlich das da und das da nicht mal auf der gleichen Höhe?
Warum ist das jetzt da unten und, und das nicht?
Das ist vom Soundtrack, ja.
Das ist vom Soundtrack, ja. So, ähm, also jetzt wollen wir noch ein Footer, ein Footer machen.
Bist du jetzt echt Partner von Gamers Only?
Und was?
Was zum Teufel ist das überhaupt?
Ich kenne auch, ich kenne auch Gamers Only AT oder so. Das war, ähm, das war so ein österreichischer Shop.
Was war, was ist denn das?
Energy Drink? Nee. Wie kommst du da drauf, dass ich Partner von denen bin?
Ey, ich würde, ich würde, ey, ohne Scheiß, ich lasse mich sofort Partnern.
Wenn es genug Geld gibt, ist mir das egal. Ob Monster, ob G-Fuel, ob, ob Dings hier ist mir wurscht.
Gib Money, ich partneres. Du hast das auf Twitter gelesen. Schick mal einen Link.
Also, Twitter. Also, wenn ich Partner wäre, dann hätte ich das selbst, selbst getweetet.
Kannst du von ausgehen. Schick mal einen Link, wo das irgendjemand erzählt hat, dass ich Gamers Only Partner wäre.
Nicht, dass die, nicht, dass die irgendeinen Müll schreiben oder so.
Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen, ich interessiere doch 2021 gar keinen mehr. Warum sollte der irgendwie ein komisches Zeug verbreiten?
Ich hab letztens gesehen, Energy Drink als Pillenform. Ja, ist das glaube ich.
Booster fürs Gehirn, da kannst du dir Koffein-Tabletten einschmeißen. Also weiß ich nicht.
Ernsthaft, ne.
Okay. Ähm, ich, wir, wir können, ich könnte Gamer, Gamer Boy, wobei Boy passt nicht, Gamer Man Badewasser verkaufen.
Gamer Boomer Badewasser, wie wäre, das wäre doch mal eigentlich Marktlücke, oder?
So, warum ist das Zeug nicht Aligned, by the way?
Juckt mich jetzt nicht, warum es nicht Aligned ist. Es bleibt jetzt einfach so.
Aber warum ist es nicht Aligned? Ach so.
Warum ist das jetzt, warum ist das so weit unten und nicht in der Mitte?
Hatte irgendjemand eine Ahnung? Ach so.
Ach so, wegen diesem komischen Eigenshit, den ich da oben kopiert habe. Das muss ja, kann ja alles weg.
Oh, äh, warum ist das jetzt nicht in der Mitte? Äh, Center.
Äh, äh, Moment, warum ist das jetzt, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich grad verwirrt.
Save, cancel, warum ist das cancel unten und nicht in der Mitte?
Kek Wait, warum? Verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Wegen eurem geplanten Stream? What? Ich glaube, du verwechselst mich, ja.
Tja, also das leuchtet mir jetzt nicht ein. Warum das nicht oben ist, aber okay. Meinetwegen, ja man.
Ist denn, wenn ich hier einen SVG rein mache, ist das dann in der Mitte? Das ist in der Mitte. Hä?
Moment, wait, wait, wait a minute. Warum ist denn ein Bild in der, warum ist es mit einem?
Und warum ist das cancel alleine nicht in der Mitte?
Oh, ich bin hochgradig höht. Ich werde, ich werde Frontendkram nie verstehen, ey.
Hat eine andere Höhe und der Save Partner hat einen Margin, okay. Also meinst du, ich muss dem Ding auch noch, ich muss, das heißt ich muss dem Ding auch eine Höhe geben oder was?
Wobei, ne. Warum flex ich das überhaupt? Gibt keinen Sinn.
Das Margin vom Save Button? Was hat das mit dem Inhalt davon? Moment, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Ach so, weil es den Margin Top hat. Ja klar. Nee. Kein Quake, ich dachte, das ist es, das ist es aber nicht. Otter.
Jetzt hätte ich auch gedacht, dass das ist, aber ist es nicht. Tja, okay, ich habe keine Ahnung warum das da unten ist.
Ich wollte kurz Licht anmachen, hier wird es mal ein bisschen dunkel.
Also das, das, das, äh, ja. Mal inspecten.
Ah, guck dir mal, guck dir mal, das Ding ist verschoben. Warum, warum das denn?
Warum ist das verschoben? Wenn man das einfach mal breakt hat's. Jetzt ist es wieder grad.
Warum ist denn das so verschoben? Guck mal. Hä?
Warte mal, BG? Hä? Aber, äh, W-W-W-W-W-Wertical Align Top, was?
Pass mal auf, pass mal auf. Boss-Champ? Hä? Hä? Das, ich verstehe es wieder nicht.
Wo kommt das her? Warum sind die Dinger nicht gleich hoch?
Wartet mal, wenn ich die Dinger nebeneinander kopiere, ist es dann wenigstens gleich?
Okay, das ist klar. What the fuck? Moment. Jetzt bin ich äußerst, äußerst verwirrt.
Äußerst verwirrt bin ich jetzt. Wisst ihr, was wir machen? Wir geben dem einfach,
okay, wir benennen, wir benennen das, mache ich. Das ist nicht Lull, sondern das sorgt dafür,
dass es irgendwie, äh, äh, immer Full ist. Wir nennen das Full anstatt Lull.
Das kann nix anderes sein. So, und jetzt bauen wir noch was, und das nennen wir jetzt Cancel,
dass es ein Cancel-Button ist, und dann. Alter. Wie kompliziert man so einen Button machen kann,
hä? Ich sag ja, Clean Coders hassen diesen Trick. So, und das ist jetzt ein Cancel-Button,
das heißt, sobald Cancel gesetzt ist, dann wird einfach der Hintergrund ausgeblendet, easy.
Also sprich, oh, Monkeys. Krieg ich jetzt den Hintergrund ausgeblendet, wenn, hier.
Da muss ich das aber so machen. Und nicht so. Das ist eh schöner. Okay, ähm, wie krieg ich das
jetzt dahin, dahin übersetzt? Also wenn, also wenn Icon, wenn Icon, dann, wenn Icon,
dann will ich W10 haben. Aber damit krieg ich kein Elzen. Ah, ah, Brain, Brain, zu klein dafür.
Mein Brain ist zu, zu, zu klein. Mein Brain ist, ist zu, zu, zu klein dafür.
Ich will gar nichts programmieren, Großart. Ich lass das jetzt so. Das war nicht schön,
aber das hat funktioniert, easy. So. Okay, ähm, ich kann da doch jetzt nicht noch einen
IF reinmachen. Jetzt irgendwann ist es doch mal gut. Das, das, das übersteigt jetzt meine
Big-Brain-Fähigkeiten. Wie, wie ich das, wie, wie krieg ich das jetzt gescheitern?
Ich will jetzt, ich will jetzt den Hintergrund ausblenden. Ich mein, ich kann den ganzen.
Easy. Pass, pass mal auf. Big, Big-Brain. Ah, yes. Ich glaub, das ist nicht Sinn und
Zweck der Sache, aber okay. Bam. Ah ne, Moment, was, was brauchen wir für? Font. Ah, yes.
Ah, yes. Sehr gut. Perfekt. Es ist zwar absolut nicht schön, aber es wird okay.
Cancel. Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut. Alles klar. Ist das nicht nice, Leute? Exquisite.
So, was wollten wir jetzt, was wollten wir jetzt als nächstes machen? Footer, ein
Footer wollten wir noch programmieren. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie es die
Engländer aussprechen. Moment. Footer. Footer. Footer. Wie Footer? Ein, wie Vogel?
Footer? Footer? Dann ist die Kokona-Variante besser. Footer, Footer. Footer, Footer wie
Pepofet-Footer, ja. So, pass mal auf, wenn ich jetzt noch sagen könnte, dass wir den
Button, den Hintergrund grün machen, dann würde ich einfach noch einen If hinzufügen
und schon ist die Button-Component auf einmal 30 Seiten lang. Ja, Handy-Aufladenstation,
ganz schlechter Gebate. So, ähm, wobei heißt das jetzt, du musst mir das wirklich
donaten? Sonst die, sonst die Abmahnung raus. Paypal-Anzeige, wenn es nicht eintrifft,
bis morgen. Genau, Donate oder Anzeige. Oi. So, also, ein Footer, ein Footer wollten wir
bauen. Okay, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten? Also, ich hab eine Idee, wie wir das
machen. Und zwar, wir haben jetzt eine Überschrift, wir haben so eine komische
Naftbar und wir haben einen Setting-Button, der nix macht, aber der ist da. Insolvenz.
Ja, man muss Prioritäten setzen. Ich finde Donation geht vor Insolvenz. Weil was
interessiert mich, ob du nach der Donation insolvenz gehst. So, also, hier machen wir
jetzt ein Footer. Diff. Footer. Nee, nee, nee, da, da nicht. Also, da sagen wir jetzt,
Klaas, kann man halt so absolut sagen, dass der unten ist, absolute Bottom. Null. Bam,
da unten ist er. Guck, da, wie es für den Footer sich gehört. Footer ist am Start.
Der Footer. Nee, äh, vier. So. Okay. Was kriegt der für einen Background? Was ist
ein guter Footer-Background? Kommt man hier wie Massive Responsive? Oh, der Footer,
der Footer, der, der, der, Footert sich da rein. Hellgrau. Noch älteres Grau. Also,
100. Ja, gut, dann, dann so wie die hier, oder? Oder, Mann? Mann. Äh. Wait. Achso,
die, die Breite ist nicht da. Was haben wir hier? Äh, rounded, full. Ich mach einfach
mal kurz das Gleiche wie da. Excellent, so lassen wir es, oder? Ist, ist eigentlich,
ist eigentlich mal was, mal was eigenes, ja? Wofür ist die Seite für nichts, dass ich,
dass ich mir Tailwind angucken kann? Ha, warum? Ah, wahrscheinlich, weil es
Absolute ist. Oh, Moment, ich hab das Diff im Diff drinne, ich Kacknoob. Warum, warum
ist hier überhaupt ein Diff übrig? Das Diff hat doch hier überhaupt nichts zu,
Moment. Das Diff, Moment, das Diff gehört zu dem Diff. Mein Footer muss da hin. Warum
wird das klein bei Absolute? Kann ich jetzt, kann ich jetzt sagen, äh, full? Äh, Monka.
Was wird das? Ich lerne Tailwind CSS gerade. Das hat keinen tieferen Sinn. Wie kriege
ich den jetzt dazu, dass der die komplette Breite frisst? Okay, Tailwind, Footer,
Footer, Absolute. Stackoverflow, beste. Was? Ah, es gibt eine extra Footer-Component,
ne, äh, es gibt mittlerweile echt eine Footer, äh, Tech-Zhaft. Okay, aber wirklich was
machen, aber, aber wirklich was machen tut er nicht, oder? So, you play. Aha. H-Screen,
das ist die Höhe, oder? Was macht H-Screen? Wow, excellent. Width-Screen. Ja, aber das
ist zu fett. MB-Auto. Hm. Okay, wie kriege ich den jetzt komplett? Kann ich dem jetzt
sagen, ähm, Width? Full-Screen. Okay, wie kriege ich den Scheiß jetzt breit? Ich meine,
das Funst aus Gründen, die sich mir nicht erschließen, nicht wirklich. Also ich kann
sagen, ich will volle Breite, aber wenn ich volle Breite habe, dann funktioniert das mit
Margin zusammen nicht. Und ich habe, eine Sache habe ich noch nicht gecheckt, wie kriege
ich mit der vollen Breite jetzt noch links und rechts ne, ne, ne Margin hin? Guck, das
geht nur links. Und rechts macht er das nett. Wie kriege ich jetzt links und rechts ne Margin
hin? Was? Margin, Right, Null und dann? Du meinst ohne, ohne die, ohne die volle Breite?
Ne. Na, wenn ich es Relative mache, das ist ja Default, dann hängt es da oben. Das will
ich ja nicht. Ich will ja schon, dass es standardmäßig unten ist. Wie wäre es mit
einem Padding und dann einem Child Diff, das nicht die volle Breite bekommt? Ähm, wenn
ich das wüsste, wie das. Warte mal, ich probiere das mal kurz mit Inline Styles, um mal zu
gucken, ob ich da das stehe. Style, Background, Right, Position, Absolute, Bottom, Null.
Oh. Und jetzt kann ich, kann ich jetzt? Margin. Das funktioniert auch so nett, gell?
Doch. What? Aha, okay, das ist irgendeine CSS-Geschichte, die ich nicht gecheckt habe.
Also, das ist kein Tailwind-Gedöns, das ist irgendeine CSS-Geschichte, die ich nicht
kapiert habe. Exzellent. So. So, wie, wie, wie, wie, wie sage ich dem jetzt, dass ich
links und rechts einen Abstand haben will? W? Full? Verstehe ich, ja, dann ist es 100%.
100%, 100, CSS, 100%, but margin, left, right. Aha, ja, exzellent. Hier, hier erklären sie
ein, wie es funktioniert. And not with, äh, okay. Ja, ist ja, ist ja gut zu wissen, aber
ach, ich glaube, ich weiß, was ich sage, ich muss sagen, left 2 und right 2 oder so.
Ah, das geht. Left. Hä? Ach, please, so schwer kann es leider nicht sein. CSS. KS. Was ist
das hier jetzt überhaupt? Warum hängen das hier so rum? Ich, ich bin da zu, zu noob-stylig
für. Warum hängen das jetzt da in der Ecke? Ah, nein, weil ich left, ich kacke habe
left. Das geht nicht zusammen. Margin, auto. Boah, wie kriege ich einen Footer, der links
und rechts Platz hat und unten an der Seite hängt? Entferne wie voll, ja, und dann?
Boah. Hatte ich das nicht eben schon mal? Das hatte ich doch ganz am Anfang schon mal.
Ach, nee, da hatte ich left und right nicht drinne. Excellent. Alles klar. Okay, so ist
es schick. Sehr nice, sehr, sehr nice. So ist das, so ist das gut. So mag ich das.
Okay, so. Und ja, gut. Was soll ich da jetzt reinmachen? Copyright, Copyright muss da
unbedingt rein, immer. Icon. Immer Copyright, was sonst? Material Design Icons, was haben
die für ein, alles mal weg hier. Gibt es da Copyright Symbol? Copyright. Auf Seite.
Come on, such was. Ja, Copyright, perfekt. MDI. Copyright, ich habe doch jetzt das
erinnern. Bei, bei Wublords. Exquisite Footer, Footer ist am Start. Ist das nicht, ist das
nicht, ist das nicht beautifully done? Nicht bei, bei. Excellent. Wublords. Ich bin begeistert,
ich bin begeistert, Leute. So, und jetzt noch, und jetzt noch, allein. Center. Dazu, dazu
kann ich nur sagen, und wir brauchen das passende Emote. Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich es
habe. Ich benutze das, ich benutze das so selten. Oh my god. Oh my fucking god. Unglaublich.
Jetzt ist einer ein Chat. Nee, nee, irgendwann ist es auch mal gut. So, ich bin, guck mal,
guck mal, wie responsive das Ganze auch schon wieder ist. Keg weight. So, und jetzt ist
die Frage, wie groß ist die Seite jetzt, wenn ich die vorhin build? 3,1. Ach so, das ist
wegen den Icons. Die Icons sind zu, zu massive fett. Die Fonts sind zu fett. Die Fonts alleine
sind ja schon 3MB oder so. Der Rest ist, Alter, sind die Fonts fett? Warum, warum sind die
Fonts so dicke? Kann er nicht einfach nur die Fonts reinmachen, die, die ich brauche?
Das kann sein, dass es rumspackt, wenn der Content länger wird. Das stimmt. Das probieren
wir jetzt mal aus. Eine Runde mehr Lorem Ipsum. Ja, das sieht kacke aus. Wait a minute. Ist
absolut nicht immer unten am Bildschirmrand. Ach nee, das ist fixed oder so, ne? Ah, yes,
yes, so ist besser. Sticky, sticky. So, jetzt ist natürlich die große Preisfrage.
Kennste? Das ist natürlich doof. Ich glaube, ich muss das alles nochmal, das war jetzt
nicht Big Pranker, ich müsste das hier alles in irgendeine Flexbox oder so stecken, weil
jetzt floatet das immer da oben drüber, was natürlich auch ziemlich das Sack ist, ne?
Aber da bin ich, da bin ich zu low-brain für. Da haben wir jetzt was für auszudenken. Aber
Sticky, macht Sticky was? Äh, ändert überhaupt nichts. Cool. Was haben wir noch? Static gibt
es auch noch. Oh. Okay. Und was passiert, wenn jetzt weniger drin steht? Ja, geil, das
ist ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, nee, das soll schon unten sein. Sticky und dann
was? Bottom. Ah, nee, haben wir ja schon. Da bin ich, da bin ich zu noobig für. Aber
es ist mir jetzt auch wurscht. Das würde ich wahrscheinlich normalerweise so nicht
machen, weil ich glaube, viel sinnvoller wäre es, man würde das hier, wobei ich kann
es ja mal ausprobieren. Der Ausgernfuchs kennt sich aus mit sowas, das weiß ich, der
hat da Ahnung. Da könnte man nämlich wirklich noch eine Flexbox drum machen, also
quasi, dass wir jetzt sagen, das da ist der Titel, aber das mal so, dass wir jetzt hier
irgendwie noch ein Diff drum machen. So. Und den Fixed machen wir mal raus. Können wir
jetzt hier noch Margin 2, nee, Margin drum machen, genau. So, und jetzt sagen wir dem
hier Class Flex, dann sieht es natürlich nicht richtig aus. Jetzt muss er sagen Column,
nee, Flex, Poll. So, und jetzt muss ich dem irgendwie sagen, dass er das letzte Element
nach unten pushen soll. Da habe ich aber keine Ahnung, wie ich das machen soll. Was
der Content Fill und der Parent ist Min, was? Last Child. Fill. Was Justify Content Space
Between. Du meinst hier? Space. So. The Space Between Tailwind. Between. What the
fuck? Justify. Justify Content. Wie macht man das mit Tailwind? Achso. Ja.
Was haben wir schon? Und jetzt? Ähm. Kompletten. Ah yes. Exquisite. Ah Moment. Ja gut,
jetzt macht er das andere natürlich. Und du? Ich habe da keine Ahnung voll, Alter. Ich
weiß nicht, was ich mache. Eigentlich ist das gar nicht mal schlecht jetzt. Ich meine,
guck mal, wenn ich jetzt hier den. Doch doch, das ist. Das passt doch eigentlich. Das ist
eigentlich gar nicht mal so übel. Was der Content Container muss noch mal in den
Diff. Hier noch mal drum herum. Richtiger Frontend Champ. Oh. Stimmt, weil es zwei
Sachen sind, ne? Ne. Das verstehe ich nicht. Die sind doch alle hier drin. Warum muss ich
da noch mal einen Diff drum herum machen? Was ist der Sinn? Was ist der Sinn von
diesem Diff? Ah. So und das muss ich jetzt alignen. Top. Wie auch immer ich das mache.
Das ist mir zu hoch. Ich fand das vorher aber gar nicht so schlecht, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist eigentlich gut so gewesen. Das ist durchaus in Ordnung so. Okay, aber jetzt
gibt es noch irgendetwas, was wir da jetzt mal mit Tailwind ausprobieren könnten. Also
wir haben einen Footer gebastelt, ein Button, eine Karte, eine Navigation, ein Chat. Ich
baue da jetzt kein Chat. Irgendein Formular oder so. Das machen wir noch mal. Wir machen
noch irgendein Formular zum Ausprobieren. Ne, die Animation bin ich zu low-brain dafür.
Wir machen den Content weg und machen da ein Formular draus. Also sprich, dann ergibt
das nämlich auch Sinn mit dem Save und Cancel hier unten. Form. Ich weiß aus dem Kopf
doch am besten will ich nicht. Wie mache ich das denn jetzt? Form und dann was? Input.
Input, einfach nur Text. Cacquade. Oh, sieht das schlecht aus. Wenn du mehrere Cards haben
willst, dann kopiere ich die einfach. Oder ich mache einen View-Component draus. Okay,
wie Style. Tailwind Form. Da gibt es doch bestimmt was Schönes für. Wait a minute. Was ist das?
Also, ich habe keinen Plan davon, aber die Form können wir erstmal weglassen. Also,
Form muss man doch eh nur drumherum machen, wenn man die im Browser eingebaute Submit-Geschichte
verwenden will, oder? Ansonsten für Styling ist das doch eigentlich egal, oder? So, also
das sieht kacke aus. Wir brauchen erstmal ein Label. Oh fuck, wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
MonkaS. Label. Oh, sieht so scheiße aus, Alter. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Okay, also das hier ist jetzt
keine Ahnung. Wir brauchen jetzt irgendeine sinnlose Sache irgendwie. Username. So, Username.
Was weiß ich? Username. Location. Ist ja egal. So, jetzt machen wir mal eine schicke. So,
irgendwie sowas. Stimmt, das muss ein Label sein, dass wenn man das nämlich anklickt.
Ne, das sieht doof aus, wenn das auf der gleichen. Ich will das nicht auf der gleichen
Zeile haben, das Label. Ja, genau, einfach Passwort. Passwort. Da können wir nämlich
hier auch gleich sagen, Typ Passwort ist doch, glaube ich, ne? Dann ist hier nämlich die
Sache gedingt. So. Was der Input muss in den Label rein? Wirklich? Ne, oder? Das Label
sagt, schreibt man auch normalerweise oben drüber. Also, das probieren wir jetzt mal
aus. Also, Label. Da kann man das nämlich dann auch anklicken. Da musste dem Ding
noch irgendwie eine ID geben, ne? Null. User. Ging das so? Genau, wenn ich jetzt da drauf
klicke, dann geht's, nehme ich da rechts rein. Max. Exzellent. So. Also, Class. Block.
Block. Sehr schön, sehr schön. Exquisite. Kann ich das nicht komplett für die ganze
Form machen? Ne, das geht natürlich nicht. Was passiert, wenn ich dem Input Block gebe?
Nix. Nix wirklich, oder? Oder? Ist das ein Unterschied? Ne. So, User Name. So, okay.
Also, da muss jetzt ein bisschen bottom 2, dass ein bisschen Abstand ist. So. So, das
Input sieht natürlich ziemlich kacke aus. Wie konnte man nochmal sagen, dass der kein
Autofill, CSS Autofill, das ging, das ging das mehr den Form, dass der das nicht macht.
Formfill? Fill? Ah, wie ging das nochmal? Autocomplete. Autocomplete. Oh, das gibt's
nicht. Das gibt's nicht. Da muss ich ihm sagen Input, da muss ich einen eigenen Style
machen. Ne. Ach, so einfach in der Form oben oder was? Okay, das ist ja easy. Warte mal,
wenn das einfach in die Form oben muss. Easy. Ja, hätte ich mal gleich gewusst, dass
sowas gibt. So, zack, zack. So, das Form sieht natürlich ziemlich beschissen aus.
Man sieht kein Cursor und nix. Also, als erstes würde ich sagen, kriegt das mal
Outline none. Sieht jetzt auch schon gleich besser aus. So, dann muss das natürlich
ein bisschen, die Höhe muss ein bisschen größer sein. Wie so, okay, okay, okay,
vielleicht nicht ganz so groß. Acht. Acht ist gut. Dann machen wir jetzt irgendwie
Font. Ne, Text. Size, Moment, Text, X, L war es dann. Tja, dann braucht das Ding
noch irgendwie einen Padding intern, sonst sieht es nämlich gar so beschissen aus.
So. Oh, mein Player ist abgekackt. Ich, ich, ich, Twinko, ich lerne Tailwind. Ich habe
keinen Plastenschimmer von Frontend Sachen. Okay, das sieht doch eigentlich ganz
brauchbar aus. Aber Text. Was gibt es noch? Text, XL, LG. So, so ist das okay.
Padding sieht kacke aus. So ist besser. Zwei. Gibt es sowas wie Padding Y? Vier?
Oh, das ist nice. Padding Y, dass der quasi nur oben und unten macht oder so.
Ja, cool. Und Padding X, zwei. Hey, das gefällt mir, das ist gut so. Sehr schön.
So, wie sieht eine gute Form aus? Was braucht man da, was braucht man da sonst
noch für? Icon, User, User Icon. Ich brauche mal ein bisschen Inspiration. Wir hatten
doch hier eben sowas. Bisschen Inspiration, so. Login Form. Sowas da. Ihh, Facebook
Login Page, Alter. Monka Christ, geh, geh weg. Ich brauche, ich brauche ein bisschen,
ein bisschen Inspiration da jetzt. Login Form. Machst du irgendwann einen Stream mit
.net Kram? Wir haben total viel.net Zeug schon gemacht. Das ist doch schick. Sowas bauen
wir jetzt, sowas bauen wir jetzt. Sowas ähnliches. Also, das heißt schon mal oben
nicht Content, sondern heißt Login. Ich muss sagen, das sieht standardmäßig schon gar
nicht mal so beschissen aus. Das einzige Problem ist, dass man das hier nicht richtig erkennt,
weil das, weil das weiß auf, auf grau ist. Das sieht kacke aus. Das heißt, das Ding
kriegt erstmal Outline weg. By the way, das hier unten mal mal. Das kopieren wir dann,
wenn es fertig ist. Also, jetzt müssen wir erstmal das Outline, Outline habe ich schon
weggemacht. Border. Shadow, das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, das ist gut. Aber ich würde sagen,
die Farbe machen wir trotzdem anders. Border. Zwei. Border. Nee, Border gray. Oh, rounded.
Moment, was hat, was hat, was hat denn unser Hintergrund für eine Farbe? Gray 200. Das
sieht kacke aus. Border blau wie die Buttons. Oh, das ist eine gute Idee. Nee, der Border
wird blau, wenn man reinklickt, oder? I love Blitzkrieg H1. Dankeschön für den Sub.
Das ist Manjaro mit E3 WM. Der Border, wenn man reinklickt, Focus, kriegt er den gleichen,
die gleiche Farbe wie die Buttons. Ups, äh, nein. Aber wisst ihr, was wir machen können?
Wir können BG vielleicht. Nein, das sieht, das sieht scheiße aus. Oh, habe ich dich
übersehen? Habe ich dich übersehen? Der Trigger, fünf Monate. Dankeschön für den
Sub. Ja, ich habe es echt nicht gesehen. Ich war so sehr in mein Werk vertieft. Dankeschön
alle für die Subs. Sorry, falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe. Ähm, ich war, ich war so
vertieft in mein künstlerisches Schaffen hier. Shiana oder Shina, ich weiß nicht. Shina,
Kina. Dankeschön für den Sub. Wahrscheinlich eher Shiana, denke ich mal. Ähm, du kannst
in der Tableconfig Primary Colors definieren. Dann kannst du die Farben als BG Primary
nutzen. Ja, könnte, könnte ich machen. Aber wir machen das jetzt so, wir machen da gar
keinen. Ey, vielleicht schaffe ich es auch nochmal irgendwann, dass man den Kram hier
gescheit eingerückt bekommt. So, Border kommt weg. Das war useless. Und wir brauchen jetzt,
wenn das Ding Fokus hat, BG Blue. Äh, nicht BG Blue, Border Blue. Und dann Border 2.
Hey, das ist doch cool. Das ist doch Porgas, oder? Wir bräuchten so eine Standard in inaktive
Farbe. Vielleicht einfach nur Border 1. Border 2. Du wolltest dir die Tage mal Vue
anschauen. Hast du dich letztens erzählt? Du hast schon irgendwie was mit Vue und irgendwie
Bulma CSS gemacht, oder verwechsel ich das jetzt? Was habe ich denn hier nochmal als
Hintergrund genommen? 100? Was hat denn das Ding hier für ein Hintergrund, dieser Block?
Login 100. Ja, passt doch. Das ist cool. Das gefällt mir richtig gut, dass man da reinklicken
kann. Porgas. Exzellent Form. So, vielleicht machen wir den Usernamen noch ein bisschen
größer. Text. Da machen wir Login auch noch ein bisschen fetter. Das sieht schon wieder
zu fett aus, oder? So, so ist schon ganz gut. Aber wir könnten Login, Login, wisst ihr was
wir machen? Text Center. Ich glaube, das ist so was, was man echt nur lernt, wenn man es
benutzt. Sonst bist du da echt am abkacken. Username mit Doppelpunkt oder ohne Doppelpunkt?
So, das ist doch eigentlich ganz nettes Form schon. So viel mehr braucht man da jetzt noch
gar nicht. Also sprich, dann kopieren wir das jetzt mal. Sagen nicht Username, sondern
Passwort. Wir machen noch Icons. Wir machen noch Icons, Leute. Warte, Top 2. Jetzt müssen
wir noch hier, dass das Type Passwort ist. Komm, wir machen noch ein Icon, oder? Wo machen
wir da ein schönes Icon hin? Wo ist denn in so einer Form immer ein Icon? Hier vorne?
Oder wo sind da Icons? Zeig mal her. Hier, hier innen drin. Guck mal so, so war es da.
So war es da, das ist doch schick. Wir machen das Username Icon, machen wir da innen rein.
Oh, wie kriegt man da innen rein ein Icon? Lowbrain. Yep, Coq. Das ist der Placeholder.
Das ist der Placeholder. Placeholder können wir auch noch machen. Account ist das, glaube
ich. Placeholder können wir auch noch machen. Das ist tatsächlich eine ganz gute Idee. Aber
Placeholder ist das, was da innen reinkommt. Ich will das Icon. Ist das der Placeholder?
Nee, ich glaube, das da vorne ist nicht der Placeholder. Nee, das ist nicht der Placeholder.
Hier hinten ist der Text, da vorne ist so ein Icon in der Form. So, aber wir können den
Placeholder rein machen. Oh, gar nicht mal schlecht. Gefällt mir eigentlich. Topics,
fünf Monate, danke schön für den Sub. Excellent Subscription. So, wie kriege ich dieses Icon
da jetzt rein? Wir fragen es der GopherFloor. Form, Input, User, Icon. W3Schools, die haben
übrigens, Moment. Das sieht ja, das kann ich auch. Das kann ich auch, dass da so ein
hässliches Ding davor ist. Background, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ja, sowas. Wie geht das?
Input. Das Styling vom Input wegmachen, dann Diff drum und das wie ein Input stylen. Stimmt.
Stimmt. Eigentlich total einfach. Das haben die hier wahrscheinlich auch so gemacht.
Die haben es mit absoluter reingeschoben, aber das sackt ziemlich. Okay, okay, also sprich,
da hoch. Also sprich quasi Diff drum. Aber das Label muss das Label auch in das Diff
rein. Wahrscheinlich funktioniert es sonst nicht. Weil ansonsten könnte ich das Label
ja rauslassen. Nee, funktioniert trotzdem noch. So, und jetzt? Und jetzt muss ich den
... Okay, das sackt aber doch richtig. Okay, also das heißt, ich mache jetzt mal das Styling
da komplett. Was ist denn das jetzt? Glass? Okay. Shadow gibt es schon mal. Nee, das ist
Müll. Das ist doch Kange. Nee, da muss ein besseren Weg für geben. Die haben nie das
gemacht. Glass Input Field. Haben die vielleicht auch funktionierende Sachen, wo man anklicken
kann? Field Center. Okay, die machen es genauso. Die machen es genauso. Die machen es genauso.
Okay. Okay, alles klar. Die machen es echt so. Also sprich, das heißt wir sagen Background
Wide. Genau. So, das Styling hier kommt komplett weg. Okay, okay, wir nähern uns. Wir nähern
uns. Wir nähern uns. Wir nähern uns. Also Input. Bloß noch Outline auf None. Es sieht doch
schon fast gut aus. Schon fast richtig. Fast, fast richtig. Diff. Okay, die Breite sollte
mal vielleicht noch mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 32 oder so. Was ist das? Ach so, das muss da
reinpassen. 40, 50. Okay, sehr gut, sehr gut. Wobei wir können doch, können wir doch nicht
sagen Width. Wir können doch sagen, der wird irgendwie so breit und dann machen wir die
Breite davon einfach voll. Nee. Funktioniert schon mal nicht. Und das muss ich noch Absolut
machen. Class. Absolut. Oh, ach nee, ich hab schon mal eine. Klasse. So. Ja. Jetzt muss
ich das aber noch ein bisschen verschieben. March in left 10 oder so. Ja, geht doch. Das
sieht doch jetzt ganz brauchbar aus. Ja, ich hab's auf Absolut gemacht, weil ansonsten
das Ding ne Zeile unten ist und ich keine Ahnung hab, was ich dagegen machen kann. So,
aber so funktioniert's auf jeden Fall auch. Hey, das ist nice. Oder auch nicht. Nee,
Pudding brauchen wir da. Ja, so ist es okay. Und jetzt einen vollen Rahmen, wenn das Fokus
hat. Ach stimmt, wie kriegen wir da jetzt Fokus hin? Wait a minute.
Wie kriegen wir da jetzt den Fokus hin? Kann ich das einfach auf dem Diff machen? Border.
Ah, fuck. Scheiße. Wie krieg ich da jetzt einen Border? Ah. Okay, jetzt ist vorbei,
Leute. Jetzt ist RIP. Ah, Moment. Ich hab gar keinen Border angegeben. Border 2. Ach,
du Scheiße. Wie krieg ich denn? Active vielleicht? Fuck. Okay, das wird nicht so ohne weiteres
funktionieren. Das muss anders gemacht werden. Das muss anders gemacht werden, Leute. Das
wird so nicht funktionieren. Wie krieg ich das gefokussed, wenn ich da drin bin? Du solltest,
glaube ich, beim Umschließen Diff einfach Position Relative machen. Aber wenn ich das
Styling auf das Input verschiebe, dann ist der Input ja nur ein Border und das Icon nicht.
Ach, du Scheiße. Wie macht man denn so was? Ich mein, an sich sieht das jetzt schon ganz
brauchbar aus. So, wir machen das so Diff, noch die Höhe irgendwie 10 oder so. Was ist das? Okay.
Ist das hässlich jetzt? Okay, das ist mir zu... Nee, also... Ha.
Ja, ja, ausgehen, Folks, glaube ich dir. Also, das ist sacked. Das machen wir mal rückgängig
wieder. Das war, glaube ich, keine gute Idee, was ich da gebastelt hab jetzt. So, das war
doch schon fast gut. Das war doch schon fast, fast gut. Guck mal, das ist fast gut. Ich
mein, wir könnten jetzt, wenn man jetzt ja irgendwie dieses Ding da reinschieben könnte,
so dass der Text später anfängt. Wobei, können wir doch, oder? Können wir doch? Wartet
mal, das ist doch eigentlich gar nicht so schwer, oder? Placeholder, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Dann
sagen wir Padding, Padding Left, keine Ahnung, 10 oder so. Ach nee. Moment, was mach ich denn da?
Padding, Padding, Padding Left, 10. Ja, das geht doch. Und jetzt kann ich es da reinschieben.
Alles gut, passt doch. Jetzt kann man eigentlich Position Absolute bei dem Ding. Oh, das ist
so ätzend. Das ist jetzt, ja, ja, ja, Pock, Pock, Pock, Label. Nee, Moment, wie konnte
man? Wow, wow, was hab ich jetzt gemacht, Alter? Ah nee, jetzt musste man auch sagen Text,
Xl oder so. Ja, ja, wir nähern uns, wir nähern uns. Pock, Champ, Pock, Champ. Ja, das sieht
schon fast gut aus, fast. Fast gut. Das ist jetzt nur ein bisschen Positionierungsfrage
noch. By the way, was geben wir dem Ding denn mal für einen Border, dass es nicht so kacke
aussieht? So, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie ich mit Tellmen Transforms mache. So, das ist
auch fast, fast schon gut. So, dann machen wir das jetzt so. Wenn du noch ein Input hinzufügst,
dann rutscht das Icon. Ja gut, ich kann sie in ein eigenes Diff packen, oder? Nö, da
rutscht kein Icon. Alles gut, Funst. Tellmen ist mehr oder weniger normales CSS, nur dass
es halt normales CSS generiert aus Text, die man irgendwie, also es hat schon vorgeneriert
das CSS, was es dann applied mit den Klassen. Also im Prinzip ist das ganz normales CSS.
Man muss halt wissen, was hinten bei rauskommt. So, Dark Sea müssen wir noch machen. Leute,
ich muss aber auch gleich was essen. So, also, das sieht schon mal kacke aus mit dem Icon
hier. Also, Icon, Text, cooleste, Text, Pray, 200, nee, kacke, 400, 500, 600, 400. So,
und jetzt kriegt es noch MarginLeft2, Left1. Leute, das sieht doch jetzt schon echt nicht
schlecht aus, oder? PaddingLeft7, das gefällt mir. Das ist top, oder? Also da kann man doch
nichts sagen. Das ist doch echt, das ist doch echt gut so. Da würde ich mich anmelden.
Nice. Das kann man doch echt zulassen. Also, das sieht doch wirklich nach einem ordentlichen
Login-Ding aus. Also, Anmeldung ist raus, würde ich auch sagen. Ich meine, was will
man da noch mehr haben, großartig, ne? Was sagt der Auskennfuchs? Der kennt sich aus,
das weiß, der ist CSS Pro. Passwort, ja, das können wir jetzt noch machen. Äh,
nicht rausklicken kann man nicht, oder? Ja, das ist doch okay so. Ich finde das okay.
Machen wir noch eins drunter. Du würdest noch ein bisschen Padding oben und unten machen.
Ja, quasi. Ja, stimmt. Also, quasi anstatt PaddingX und PaddingLeft beißt sich. Ja, ja,
okay. Also, PaddingRight wollen wir auch nochmal. Okay, naja. Ihh! Was ist das? Na gut,
auf der anderen Seite, wie soll es denn auch sonst sein, ne? Okay, wie soll es denn auch
sonst sein? Ich meine, das Icon muss ja davor sein. Okay, also PaddingY4 oder sowas. Ja!
Oh! Äh, jetzt stimmt es ja von der Höhe nicht mehr. Sackt jetzt. Da muss ich das
noch ein bisschen größer machen. Das sieht jetzt aber kacke aus. Vorher war besser.
Nee, ich lasse es so, wie es vorher war. Das ist jetzt so. Aber wenn man da auf das Icon,
was kann ich denn machen, dass er das fokussiert, wenn ich auf das Icon klicke? Ich könnte
das hier als Label machen. Das wäre quasi das da. Ha! Bäm! Massive! Braucht da kein
Überschrift. Was jetzt natürlich noch geiler wäre, wenn es fokussiert ist, dass das auch
blau wird. Da hört es dann aber schon wieder auf, weil da müsste man eben eine JavaScript-Geschichte machen. Sonst, sonst wird das nichts. Perfekt. So. Okay, ähm. Ihh! Was jetzt?
Cacquait! Wo ist das Problem? Immer Divstrom. Wenn man Divstrom macht, dann fixt das alles.
Easy! Was ist mit Fokuss? Ja, keine Ahnung, was wir mit Fokuss machen sollen. So, Passwort.
Was ist denn ein gutes Icon für Passwort? M-D-E-Key oder sowas hieß das doch.
Icon-O-Key. Po-Punkt. Placeholder. Und hier Placeholder. So ist es schick. Das gefällt mir richtig gut jetzt.
Man könnte hier noch ein bisschen mehr Padding machen. Padding-Left-Mama-8. Dann bappt es nicht so dran.
Das ist eine richtig gute Login-Form. So bleibt das jetzt. Ah, Input-Teil-Passwort, ja. Ja, nice. Da würde ich mich anmelden, Leute.
Lock. Lock kennt man glaube ich eher, ne? Bei einem Fokus auf den Input kannst du das Icon färben. Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt.
Aber ich weiß nicht, wie ich das machen kann ohne Javascript.
Weil ich weiß nicht, ob das erkennt, dass es Active ist. Erkennt das Label, dass es Active ist? Oder Fokus, Fokus hat?
Nee, wisst ihr, er kennt das Ding nicht. Was ein Button hinter Passwort, dass man auch sieht, ob man das Passwort richtig geschrieben hat. Hä?
Ja, das ist jetzt, das mit Save und Login, das ist jetzt ja nur Optik, ja.
Das Mumu-Farm. Nee, Peach-Peach. Mumu-Farm hatten wir eben auch schon. Das geht mit Group-Focus. Was ist Group-Focus?
Focus-Gruppe, alles klar. Agile-Focus-Gruppe. Was für ein Ding?
Focus-Within. Was ist das? Input-Group?
Oh, jetzt wird es, jetzt wird, jetzt wird exzellent. Group-Focus? Ah. Ja, Moment, aber nur wenn es innen drin ist, oder? Nicht für das Label.
Moment, Text? Nee, nee, ich texte. Nee, nee, nee, so funktioniert das nicht. Oder vielleicht auf das Diff?
Ja, wenn das innen drin ist, dann funktioniert das. Aber ich kann ja wohl den, das kaum in das Input rein machen, oder?
F. Das funktioniert in dem Fall glaube ich nicht. Aber das Diff hat ja keinen Fokus, wenn ich hier reinklicke.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus. Group. Das Group. Group-Focus.
Hopp. Hopp. Kannst du noch ein Vorlese-Button? Ja, das könnte man, das könnte man schon machen, ja. Aber das will ich jetzt nicht designen, zumal die Seite eh nur zum Üben ist.
In den Input? Wie in den Input? Aber ich will doch das Label färben und nicht den Input.
Im Input könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass es sogar funktioniert. Oder auch nicht. Nee, da bin ich zu low-brain für, jetzt das checken.
Was ist das? Focus within CSS. Aha.
Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Class. Focus.
Okay, okay, so müsste man das doch irgendwie gebacken bekommen. Text. Text yellow.
Okay, das hier färben funktioniert schon mal, weil ich hier den Text nicht gesetzt habe.
Aber ich will ja, dass das andere blau wird. Text. Okay, dann machen wir das so. Text ist gray. Wenn das Focus ist, wird das blau. 500.
Was haben wir da? Blue 100. Okay, das funktioniert. Jetzt muss ich hier nur noch den Text wegmachen.
Okay, und hier überschreiben wir jetzt die Text mit, keine Ahnung, black. Nice, guck mal. Bam.
Excellent, excellent. Jetzt wird es blau. Äußerst schick, äußerst schick. Kann man irgendwie das Spacing von dem Cursor, ich weiß, jetzt wird es echt eklig.
Das Spacing zwischen Placeholder und Cursor ändert. Kann man den Placeholder irgendwie verschieben oder so? Oder kann man den Placeholder wegmachen, sobald man reinklickt?
Naja, so, aber das ist sehr schick, das gefällt mir. Das ist exquisite. Und da könnten wir jetzt eine View-Komponente draus extrahieren, aber das machen wir jetzt nicht, weil ich hab übelst Hunger.
Lock. Ja, nice. Also das muss ich sagen, das gefällt mir jetzt. Das hat was. Haben wir heute ein bisschen Tailwind gelernt, Leute.
Da würde ich mich einloggen. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, bestes Passwort. Bam, login. Ah, Moment hier, hier. Kannst du den Padding erhöhen?
Dann schiebt sich noch weiter. Doch, das gefällt mir. Exzellent. So mag ich das. Border-Radius, ich weiß nicht, ob man das großartig ändern kann. Gucken wir mal.
Ähm. Ach hier, rounded. Rounded MD. Ja, so ist noch besser. So ist nice. So ist noch besser, oder? Jawoll. Exquisite. Ich bin begeistert, Leute.
Er ist noch captures, ja. Das gefällt mir richtig gut jetzt. Sehr, sehr gut. Exzellent, exzellent. Dann gucken wir mal, ob ich irgendjemand hosten kann.
Aber ich muss erstens mal übelst dringend pinkeln und ähm, was essen. Leute, es war schön, dass ihr dabei wart heute.
Ein bisschen viel rumprobiert, aber ich meine, so lernt man auch was. Aber ich glaube, es kann sich sehen lassen, dass ich absolut scheiße bin.
Also richtig scheiße, was Frontend-Design angeht. Und dass ich von Tailwind keine Ahnung habe. Ich glaube, das kann man so lassen.
Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Macht's gut. Wir sehen uns. Michael 50 Billionen. Ich kann leider nichts dran ändern, aber wir müssen noch einen Custom-E-Mode machen.
Alles klar, macht's gut. Bis dann. See you.